Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my god, today has been so busy for me.
I have been in meetings the whole day.
I have some good news!
I finally have my new company bank account!
Yay!
I felt so fucking stupid talking to the banker.
I made the appointment last week, but the earliest they could do was today.
I made the appointment and I felt so fucking stupid.
She was like, do you have a credit line?
I was like, credit line?
Does this bank account, does your other bank account have a credit line?
I'm like, I'm sorry, what's a credit line?
She's like, does it or does it not have?
And I'm like, I don't know what the credit line is!
I don't know!
I felt so fucking stupid.
And she was like, how the fuck did you open your other bank account?
How do you not know?
And then they...
They were asking so many questions!
And I was like, I don't know.
I was like, I'm sorry, I don't...
Can you rephrase that?
Like, what does that mean?
Anyway, she said other things too.
But like, I...
I was like, I don't know, I'm sorry.
And she's like...
And I was like, oh, can I have a...
Can I have a credit card with...
Open for this account too?
And she was like, oh, you have to apply for it.
And I was like, okay.
And then she's like, okay, how much are you willing...
Are you asking for?
I was like, I don't know.
Like, what are the options?
And she's like, well, there's no options.
It's basically, give me a number amount.
I was like, there's no...
I don't know.
I don't know how much I'm gonna use this credit card.
I just...
I just wanted a credit card.
I didn't know.
And she's like, it can either get accepted or rejected.
Depending on how much you're asking for.
I was like, what is considered high?
What is considered high?
What is considered low?
And I was like, 3000.
I just said a random number.
I was like...
I'll have 3000 for my credit card, please.
Because I don't know.
And I was like...
Because they can raise the credit.
The...
It's so...
I don't know.
I was under pressure.
She didn't give me any options.
She...
I didn't know.
I was like...
I'll take $3000 as the credit card.
And she's like, 3000.
I was like, yes.
And I was like, okay.
And she's like, okay.
And then she just wrote 3000.
I was like...
I was so confused.
You don't understand.
I'm sorry.
I got a message from Ellen.
He's like, can you join this game right now?
And I'm just like, I'm sorry.
I just started my stream.
I'm beating...
I'm beating Wukong finally.
Oh my God.
Sorry.
Anyway...
I know what the fuck feather party is.
I think like, wait.
Wait, let me double check.
What is this?
What is he streaming real quick?
Is this?
Oh, my God.
Oh, that's a lot of people.
Oh, I would have been so scared.
It's a lot of hard hitters there, too.
What
do you mean?
I need to play Wukong.
What the fuck do you mean?
We need to fucking beat this game, chat.
We need to beat this game, guys.
It's been a whole entire month, chat.
Today is the day.
Where we beat Wukong.
Anyway, as I was saying...
As I was saying, I was so fucking...
Oh, my God.
I was...
I was so fucking...
Nervous and everything.
Because, like I said, I...
I was just like, I don't know.
There's so many...
There's so many questions.
And I'm like, I don't know how to answer this.
And I feel like I could tell she was like, how...
I could...
I could tell that the lady was, like, really annoyed.
Because she's like, how do you not know?
And I'm just like, I'm sorry.
Because I have another bank account.
She's like, how did you open this bank account?
We can't...
We can't answer these questions.
How do you have these many credit cards?
And you can't...
And I'm like, I'm sorry.
I'm...
I'm doing this for the first time.
With no help.
This is...
This is my first time.
But, like, we...
We're okay.
Everything is fine.
Everything is...
Fine.
Lunar means thank you for the magenta soupa.
Thank you.
That's my first day.
Anyway.
And also, like, when she, like...
I don't know what's going on.
But, like, she was in the phone call.
I was like, oh, can you...
Can you send me the form?
Can you let me know what my routing number and account number is?
So I can accept wire transfers from, like, companies and spots.
And stuff like that.
And she was like, yeah, yeah, after you sign all of this after the call, I'll send it to you.
And I was like, yeah, thank you so much.
It's like, because I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know what my Y routing number is.
And then after I sign everything, I was like, I wrote an email.
I was like, hey, so where's the form?
And then she was like, oh, go to your branch.
Go to your, go to your bank's branch and ask them.
And I'm like, I was like, but you said go
to my bank's branch.
What do you mean?
Anyway, I have my new bank account, but I have to go to the bank tomorrow.
I have to go to the bank tomorrow.
So I can figure out what my routing and account number is.
I mean, I have my account number in the documents.
It says what my account number is.
But like, I don't know what like the other stuff is, though.
Like, I don't know what I don't know what my routing number is, which is very unfortunate.
Because like I said, I need I need my routing number to be.
I need my routing number.
To like know, to like know how to do wire transfers or like how to get paid by other companies.
So I got to figure that out.
I have online banking.
No, because they're like, not yet, because it because it can't it doesn't go instantly.
They're like, oh, you have to you have to wait until you receive your debit card.
And then.
And then when you get your debit card, it should have like a password to to open your online banking account.
And then and then, well, not just the routing, though, but a transit number, too.
And was it the like, just numbers?
There's so many numbers.
Why the fuck even Saikudo was like, Saikudo just messaged me.
He's like, Fender party right now.
I'm like, I'm sorry.
I told I told him I can't.
I'm really beating Wukong today.
I just started my own stream and I need to be right.
I promise to beat Wukong.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I would love to.
But I can't spin off.
I want to be a month.
OK, anyway.
Speedrun Toki, you can feed it to Marr.
Guys, No, we are going to beat Wukong.
I'm not going to delay Wukong to another weak chat.
I.
I did.
I was like, are you serious?
I said no.
Are you proud of me?
I actually said no.
Oh my god.
I fucking did it, guys.
I actually said no.
Anyway, what was I saying?
What the fuck?
Oh, is fetter party like... Oh, fetter party is like pummel party, but like with fetters.
Anyway, what was I saying?
Oh, yeah.
So, I have to go to the bank tomorrow to like...
And someone was like, what about your checkbook?
Guys, I literally just opened my account today on the phone.
I'm not getting anything.
I literally opened my bank... like I had the bank account opened literally this morning.
It was like an hour and a half phone call.
Yeah, on the phone.
Because...
Because they can only do it on the phone.
I was like...
And they were like...
Oh my god.
They're like, you can only do it by phone.
I was like, can I do it by PC or like at the branch?
And they're like, no, you can't do it at the branch.
You have to...
You have to do it on the phone.
I'm like, okay.
I was booking an appointment online to see if I could book it at my branch.
And they're like, no, it can only be done on the phone.
And I'm like, what?
I'm just like, what?
And I was like...
And I called them.
Because like on the internet, that's what it said when I was trying to book an appointment.
And then...
And then I called them, like called the customer support.
And I was like, hey, can I get an appointment with my branch to open my own business account?
And they're like, well, we don't do it by branch.
Sorry.
We got to do it by phone.
I'm like, what?
By phone?
But you can...
I mean, I give you my documents anyway.
So, by phone it is.
By phone it was.
And well, it's opened.
It's...
It's open.
At least now.
But yeah, that was...
And then they're like, no, you can't do it by phone.
And then I had another meeting I had to go to.
I had a separate other meeting that I had to go to.
It's a secret meeting.
So I can't say what it was.
But yeah, that was my day.
It was just full of meanings and like sadness.
And then right after that, my friends made me watch them play deadlock.
And so that was more sad.
.
The pain train never ends.
They're like...
They're like, do I play?
I was like, no, that's okay.
I'll just...
I'll just watch.
I know, guys.
I know I said I'll never...
I won't touch deadlock until it releases...
Until it publicly releases.
But sure, Fort Peer pressured me.
I was talking to him and he was like, no.
No, Doki.
It's going to be the next big game.
He's like, I swear it's going to be the next big game.
Everybody is going to be playing it when it comes out.
It's going to be the next shooter game.
And he was like, there was 150 concurrent...
150,000 concurrent players yesterday.
And it's still on invitation only.
And it's the second most wishlist game.
So you should really learn it.
It's really worth it.
And then I was like...
And then I'm just like, okay.
And he was like, you don't play MOBAs, right?
I was like, no.
And he was like, yeah, the moment you learn the MOBA mechanics, it'll be so easy.
You would love it so much.
And you'll get addicted to it.
I'm like, okay.
Okay.
I'm like, what are you...
Are you fucked?
I'm just like...
And you know, my expression is just like, okay.
Okay.
I'm learning... I'm learning deadlock today.
Not today.
On Saturday.
And we'll see how it goes.
We'll see how long I last on deadlock.
It's just because I have no MOBA experience.
That's like the worst part.
I didn't grow up with MOBAs at all.
So it's like it's so hard to understand for me.
It's so hard because like sometimes it's either the games go... like nothing happens for like 15 to 20 fucking minutes.
Because like I played one game with my friends.
I think like three... two to three days ago.
I played one game with my friends two to three days ago.
And then like... and then like I was in the lane with one of them and literally nothing happened in that lane for 15 to 20 minutes.
We stayed there for...I... I swe cows I felt like I was going fucking crazy.
Like, all we did was just poke the enemy.
They don't do anything.
We can't do anything.
Because the moment we try to engage, they run away.
The moment they try to engage us, we run away.
And it's...
And I'm just like... I'm like I don't fucking know.
I was like I'm so bored.
I..
I was like...
I'm so bored.
And like nothing happened.
Oh my god.
I swear I almost, I almost de-seed.
I almost like right click quit right there.
I like, I was so, oh my god.
And then we were at the same area.
The same fucking area for 15 to 20 minutes.
And I was like, I'm going fucking crazy.
I was literally gonna tab and right click and close.
I would have done it.
I was going fucking crazy.
Nothing was happening.
We literally fucking shot the same thing for so long.
I felt like I was a cog in the machine.
And then I hear my two, my two other friends fucking talking about the kills they're getting.
And how they're like, yeah, good job.
And I'm like, you guys are getting kills?
Like stuff is happening in your side?
What the fuck is going on on my side?
Why?
Like, I just, cause we're on, we're in a call.
We were force stacking.
And I'm like, you got kills?
What the fuck are we doing?
And I'm just like talking to my other friend, like the friend that was laying with me.
I'm like, what the fuck?
Why are they getting kills?
What are we doing?
I'm so fucking, I'm so confused.
Anyway, anyway.
And then after like we lost.
Um, my friends were just like, uh, yeah, you just didn't, you just didn't have the right build.
And I'm like, I don't fucking...
You just didn't have the right build.
And you didn't understand, you didn't farm enough.
And I'm like, what the fuck do you mean I didn't farm enough?
What do you...
I'm like, what does that mean?
What does it mean?
What does
that mean?
I'm literally just shooting.
I'm literally the minion slash creep, whatever you call it.
Like, I just, I'm just...
How do I farm more?
How do I farm correctly?
I just...
I don't even know.
I don't, I don't know.
Anyway, maybe Saturday will be better, guys.
Maybe, maybe Saturday will be like...
Maybe, maybe Saturday...
Saturday will be different.
Yeah.
So yeah, that was...
That was...
That was my last couple of days.
Maybe, you know, maybe I'll Stockholm Syndrome my way into Deadlock by then.
By the time Deadlock fully comes out, maybe the Stockholm Syndrome will fully hit at that point.
Like...
Or like...
I would finally understand MOBAs.
Like, that's...
That's like honestly what I hope for.
Anyway...
Today we're gonna try and beat Wukong.
A lot of people are saying that that might not be impossible.
Because it's like the two hardest bosses in the game today.
So like...
This is gonna be a bit rough.
This is...
I mean, if I was able to beat Orphan of Cause...
Okay.
Is it more difficult than Orphan of Cause?
Or like...
Similar?
I need to know.
Is it similar?
Or like...
More?
Less?
Or easier?
I just...
It's easier?
Okay, we're fine.
Then it won't take me six hours.
If it's...
I didn't even learn to parry, guys.
In Bloodborne.
I never learned to parry.
So...
So like...
It should be fine at that point.
If I never learned to parry...
For Orphan of Cause in Bloodborne...
I don't need to learn here.
I don't...
I...
I don't need...
I don't...
I don't need to learn here.
Okay.
Let's go.
Put it on...
Okay.
We'll see how this goes.
Chat.
Or...
Anyway.
We're...
We're gonna try and beat Wukong today.
That is our goal.
Actually, I didn't pay $60 to block.
Oh, I also bought the new Mickey...
The...
The remastered Mickey game.
Yes, I watched State of Play.
My opinion...
The only thing...
The only good announcement they did was Dynasty Warriors.
And even then, it's gonna be around...
I have to wait next year for it.
So, like, what's the point in life?
Other than that, it was pretty mediocre.
It was, like, 200,000 remasters.
As always.
Oh, my God.
I forgot this area is so fucked.
I forgot.
This is the fucked area, too.
Okay.
What do I want?
I realized I never upgraded any of my stuff.
My stances.
Should I actually start?
Should I actually start upgrading my stances?
Nah.
Where the fuck are these?
Okay.
I don't know.
Hmm.
Oh, yeah.
The pole dance.
We don't want that.
Let's see.
Okay.
I feel like...
I don't know if I actually need...
Do I need any...
I need to, like, upgrade any stances, though.
I personally like thrust.
Many say smash dance is good.
I haven't used the smash one in so fucking long.
Let's see.
Upon seeing and hitting the enemy with Resolute Strike.
When charging, perfect dodges.
Okay.
I don't know.
Because, like, I never actually had to use it in a way.
So, like, hmm.
It was never useful to me.
Yeah.
It's, like, the least mobile, too.
Why am I...
Okay.
Wait.
Let me...
Let me double check real fast.
Let me double check.
I'm just...
I'm just double checking how fucked up I am right now.
Real quick.
Just...
Just double checking how...
If I'm okay at the moment.
I'm okay.
Like, I don't understand.
Like, I don't...
Okay.
Let me...
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna disappear a little bit real quick.
Oh, my God.
This is so annoying.
I don't know if it's because of the area.
I...
Oh, I...
I closed the game.
My bad.
I accidentally closed the game.
That's...
That's my bad.
I right-clicked close.
But...
No way.
We're off to a good start, chat.
We're...
We're off to a really good start right now.
Okay.
Things are...
Things are slowly getting better.
Okay.
Let's see.
All right.
This should be fine.
Right?
Are you a-okay?
Are you a-okay, me?
All right.
Here we go.
Okay.
I should show up soon.
There we go.
All right.
Okay.
Where was I?
Brain melted already?
When you have, like, an one-hour-plus talk with the fucking bank?
Yeah.
No.
The one hour plus talk with the bank really... really took me out of it.
Nothing happening for 50 minutes, isn't that Apex?
Oh, but at least... no, Apex it's like three to four minutes at least.
But like, no, the 15 minutes for...
Because at least like, when you see the enemy, somebody dies.
When I see the enemy, we just... we just fucking...
Like, fucking, I don't know, blow bubbles at each other.
Like, I swear.
Like, we fucking... we fucking blow bubbles at each other.
And then... and then... nothing.
That's how I feel.
Okay, let's see.
I have four, but I don't...
I have four, but I don't know.
I don't know.
What to use?
After successful hit, performs this, unleashes a tactical retreat.
Let's see, the thrust stance.
Heavy...
S1 leverage is following, grants a massive focus upon hitting the enemy with Resolute Strike.
I don't know.
I'm just gonna grab this.
I'll grab this.
Wait, with significantly reduced damage.
Oh shit!
No!
Wait!
I'm getting rid of that.
Sorry, I didn't read the... I didn't read the last part.
I was like, whoa!
And then significantly reduced...
No, I don't want that.
I don't want that.
Get that out of here.
Reclaim.
I don't want that.
Yeah, but it like reduces the damage.
I love damage, chat.
Oh no.
Maybe I don't.
Maybe I just... I just don't.
I don't feel like I don't need to upgrade these.
Yeah, fuck it.
I tried to read a little bit, but I realized reading was a mistake.
There was no need to.
There was no need to keep reading.
Okay, critical hit.
I'll grab critical hit.
Each talent level significantly increases.
Each talent level significantly reduces.
Let's see.
I still have a lot, so...
I feel like I don't need to get that.
Immobilize.
You know what?
Maybe I'll grab more immobilize.
Yeah, I'll grab more immobilize.
And then that should be good.
Yeah, fuck it.
We'll go with that.
I think it's the area I'm in.
I think the area is just too pretty.
I'm pretty sure it's the area I am right now.
The area... There's too much stuff going on in this area.
There's no other reason.
I don't like how I did it.
It has to...
What?
How did it reset itself?
When did this reset itself?
Okay, it's not... Okay, we figured it out.
We figured it out.
Holy fuck.
I was like, man, why is this so fucked up?
It had to be, like, just today.
I was like, there's no way.
It was fine.
It was so fine last time.
No, this was literally today that it reset itself.
I don't even remember what my settings were.
I don't remember what my settings were, chat.
I don't...
When did this happen?
When?
There was a patch today?
Oh, my God.
There was a patch.
I was like, what the fuck?
What happened?
Okay, what... I don't remember what was low.
I can't remember.
God, it makes so much more sense now.
It actually made so much more...
I was like, there's no way.
Okay, now we should be better.
Okay.
Okay,
we're not better yet.
We're not better yet.
Guys, does anyone remember what our...
Oh, you need to restart it?
Okay.
Okay, we're gonna restart it.
I was like, that's so fucking weird.
Because, like...
I was like, there's something wrong.
Because, like, the game was...
Last stream, we weren't lagging at all.
Third time's the charm, chat.
Guys, we're beating Wukong today.
We're beating...
We're...
Hahaha.
Today's the day!
We just gotta figure out...
We are...
We just gotta figure out the...
The first...
The first difficulty is just fixing the settings.
Fixing the settings.
Guys, look, we're beating...
The moment we beat the hardest boss today, which is fixing the settings, it's over.
Guys, it's over for everybody.
Like...
Like, we win.
In the moment we fix the settings.
We fucking win.
The true final boss.
Yeah, the true final boss.
The goddamn settings.
This is it, guys.
This is it!
We will win when we fix this!
Okay.
Okay, this should be better now.
This...
Okay.
There was no change.
Hahaha.
But...
I mean, it's a little better.
It's...
It's a little better, guys.
Okay, what were my other settings, guys?
What was it?
Hahaha.
Was 70...
DLSS was 75%.
Okay, we got that.
Okay.
Okay, and then what?
Medium everything?
No, it was...
We had some that was medium.
I remember.
Um...
Alright.
Guys...
Guys, we need to fix the settings first!
Okay, turn down reflection.
Was it...
Was it reflection quality?
Okay, we'll put medium there.
And then...
Was it vegeta...
I don't remember.
Was it visual?
No, visual effects was alright.
Link, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Alright.
What else?
Uh...
Was it shadow?
Well, yeah, we didn't care about shadows, right?
Okay.
Alright.
This is...
Uh...
I think that's good.
What is this?
Slightly increases attack?
I mean, that's pretty good.
Consider it deals damage to surrounding enemies upon considerably increasing...
Increases critical hit.
Um...
To avoid the next fatal blow.
Okay.
We like that.
Uh...
Guess we get...
Use the new item?
Uh...
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh...
Vegetation was low?
Was it?
I remember I wasn't high for the quality.
Um...
Let's see.
For the fatal blow to work?
Uh...
Okay.
Alright.
So, I guess I'll put vegetation quality medium then.
And then that should be fine.
We should be okay now.
Oh, I set vegetation to low?
I'm pretty sure I set it to medium.
Because I was like, bro...
It's...
It looked so ugly if I did it.
I...
Okay.
I mean, if...
We don't use that, right?
I use the...
Increase attack then.
Increase experience.
Increase chance of obtaining weapons.
Increasing materials.
Uh...
Damage reductions for all burn.
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh, okay.
Now...
Okay.
We did it.
We did it, guys.
We fucking did it.
Oh my god.
We fucking did it, guys.
Let's fucking go.
We fixed it.
Can we fix it?
Oh, where do I go?
Oh my god.
We're finally playing the fucking video game.
Oh my god!
Team!
This is it.
It only took us thirty minutes.
But we're finally fixing...
We fixed it.
Oh, here's baby Buddha.
It's Buddha.
Hello Buddha.
We fixed...
Guys!
We beat the final boss.
Baby Buddha, why do you have so many polygons?!
Polygons!
What is that?
Oh no, not the snow!
That's more polygons!
My frames!
Every piece of snow takes more one of my frames!
The more snow it falls, the more frames I lose!
The particles!
Not the particles!
Alright, here we go.
Every snowflake is a unique model.
Okay, alright.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I forgot how fucked up the snow was.
I forgot.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
Oh, why is there so many of them?
Guys, sorry, we have not beat the final pause yet.
Guys, is that visual effect quality?
What is the snow?
Yeah, okay, I'm turning that to low.
Oh, my face.
We're at phase two of the boss fight.
Oh my god, get this fucking snow out of my fucking screen.
Oh my god.
That's phase two of the stupid snow particles.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Okay, it's a lot better.
See guys, when the snow disappears, we can actually move.
Alright, nice.
Why did they have to make each individual snow unique, a unique model?
That's so fucked.
Woo!
Okay.
I just need to remember how to play this game again.
Alright.
Wukong went west and finally arrived in Canada.
We're making it to Canada, guys!
We're making it!
Okay, we'll travel over.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god, please.
I swear to god, every little snow my little monkey feet touches is fucking me up.
It's fucking me up.
Hello?
Oh, it's you!
Please.
I know you're beautiful, but please spare me some fucking frames.
Like, I...
I know you're supposed to be like one of the beautiful guys out there, but please, I really need my frames, Erlang.
I really...
I really need my frames.
Please stop taking them away.
Maybe that's the only way.
He has no choice.
I...
Oh, shit.
Wait, what?
Oh, shit!
Please!
Oh, fuck!
I can't...
My frames!
Erlang, please!
Oh my god, wait!
Okay, we're gonna play...
Okay, phase three.
Okay, low.
I can't...
I can't see anything!
I literally can't even fucking...
Oh my god, I can't process anything!
Wait...
Oh my god!
Was it...
No, we're fine.
Oh my god, okay, we don't need to see their beautiful hair.
Okay, things are fine now.
Things should be fine now.
That's fucking right.
What you gonna do now?
That's fucking right!
Get over here!
Get your ass over here!
Oh, shit!
I'm so sorry!
I did not mean to do that, but I guess I'll whip you now.
I'm gonna whip!
Whip!
Whip it real good!
Wait, why are you attacking?
Hey, you can transform too?!
Wait, that's not fair!
Oh, shit!
Okay, that's fine.
Whoa!
Fucking big baby time!
That's right!
Big baby time!
Oh, fuck!
Okay!
Stance!
Okay, nice.
Oh, that's fine!
That's fine!
Oh, that's a lot of tigers!
That is a lot of tigers!
I mean, wolves!
Oh my god!
What?!
Sorry, but like...
He doesn't... Okay...
He can immobilize too?!
Alright, that's cheating, actually.
That's actually cheating.
That should not be allowed.
Wait, what?
Is that a grab?!
Oh my god, Erlang, please!
My frames are dying because of...
Like, I'm...
I don't know if you guys can notice it, but...
My frames are actually dying because of this fucker!
I...
What the fuck is that?!
And I dodged it!
Fuck!
Okay, that's out.
Okay!
That hurts me?!
Alright!
Immobilize doesn't do jack shit, apparently.
Now I know.
Alright.
At least I know that now.
Fuck you, Erlang.
I know you won like 300 of our battles before, but like, this time it'll be...
Guys, no!
You don't understand.
This time, I'm gonna win.
But like, not this round, though.
Not this round!
Not this ta- Wait, he transforms when I tra- WHAT?!
He transforms when I transform!
Wait!
That should be illegal!
Oh my god, Erlang, please!
Do not make me play this- Play this fight in like- Guys, I'm actually- I might actually play this fight in low quality.
Like- Like, at this point!
That could not- It's just not- I can't see anything!
Like- Like- Like- I can't- The phrase for this is- Okay.
What?
Like, I actually might have to.
I- You know, I might actually have to.
At this rate.
Oh, fuck.
Every time he parries me!
That's right, not pretty anymore when you're fucking low quality, fish.
That's fucking- Are you serious?!
Please stop.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't know you could do all that.
Oh, haha!
You missed, bitch!
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Whoa!
That's alright.
I got Cloud Step.
And I'm fine with that.
Oh!
Okay.
Guys, I just want you to know it's actually so difficult right now!
Oh, that's fucking- Oh, I missed it!
It's in real!
Fuck, okay.
Oh, no, I didn't mean to heal!
This is so bad!
I pressed the- I pressed the wrong button!
Shoot!
Okay.
Yeah, that's right.
Interrupt this, bitch.
Interrupt this, you fucker.
Fucking right!
Interrupt this, and then big baby!
Oh, oh no.
Oh, what is that?
What is that?
Reload.
I don't know what that is.
What is that?
Oh, Cloud Step!
I don't know what that is.
I don't know what- That hits me?!
No!
Oh, God.
That's right.
You can't transform when I'm here now.
You can't transform now.
Oh, he- Guys, he transformed.
He transformed, guys!
That's JP Liga!
That's right.
Can you transform this?
Everybody deserves to get whipped!
That's fucking rare life!
It's whipping time!
Oh, my God.
But I still am gonna start whipping!
Goodbye.
Cool.
I'm running out of heals, guys!
I'm running out of heals!
No!
That was such a good run!
You know what?
For first try, I think that was pretty decent.
Okay.
We're gonna do this fight at like the lowest graphic possible.
I don't know what is wrong with him.
But he actually takes up so much.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I need to make sure.
Okay, let me make sure that I'm also on.
Okay, I am on.
I am on 280.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
It's a boss fight.
Guys, I don't know if you guys could tell.
But it was so fucking rough.
Like...
It was so rough, chat.
It was so rough fighting this fucker.
I felt like I was fighting.
With like...
I have to predict the future.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
No, no, guys.
You don't understand.
It was so fucking rough.
Guys, you don't understand.
You need vegetation on low.
Okay.
Is it not on low?
He's just too beautiful, guys.
Like...
Guys.
He's just too beautiful.
Like, we gotta turn down these graphics, guys.
Like...
He's...
He's too handsome, guys.
Like...
Majority of my frames went to boost up his...
His fucking looks.
Alright.
Too beautiful for him to be rendered at this point.
Yeah.
Okay, but what if I go first?
I...
That's fucked, bro.
That's...
That's... Oh, wait.
I still have it.
Good.
Okay.
Now...
Okay, I was gonna say it.
That is so fucked.
That is so...
When he ran past the tornado?
That should be illegal.
Here.
It's time.
It's time, guys!
Guys!
This is it!
We gotta do this work together, monkeys!
Work together!
We gotta work together!
Get this out!
Oh, shit.
Okay, phase two.
Oh, god.
I run.
Monkey together strong.
Monkey together so strong.
Can I use this?
What?!
Okay.
You know what?
Fuck you.
It's whipping time.
Okay, I just need to dodge this.
That's right!
I stay!
Oh, wait.
What?
Wait, wait a minute.
That's right.
I'm gonna stay a horse.
Of course!
That's... oh, wait, again?
Wait, that's not fair.
Wait, what?
You get to do that twice?
I can only transform once!
Whip!
It doesn't matter if you're part of the heavenly court.
Even politicians need to get whipped.
Oh, shit.
You think I don't know?
You think I don't know about the secret whippings?
I'm... okay, I'm sorry.
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry!
Okay.
There's no way he sees me.
Haha!
You didn't see.
He dodged Big Baby!
Oh!
How?!
How am I doing worse?
Oh my god, how am I doing worse?!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I don't understand.
He has so many new movesets.
It's... I'm off my groove!
It's so...
Oh, god.
Oh, no!
Okay.
No, not again!
Please don't grab me!
I'm just a monkey!
You have everything!
You got the logs and everything!
It's not fair!
And now he's a bird?!
Why do they give you so many moves?!
Get grappled!
I thought they nerfed grapplers!
So not fair.
They should not be allowed to do that.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Guys, I don't think this is the right guys.
Like, he does...
Like, I can't, guys!
Jesus Christ.
Guys, this is my...
Guys, I don't know why my first run was the best one out of all of this.
Like, it got sidestepped.
How?!
HOW?!
No, it's over.
It's so over.
My first run was the best out of everything.
This is not fair.
He has so many cool moves, and I have, like... I'm just a monkey.
I'm just...
I'm just a fucking monkey.
I don't understand.
How do I dodge that?!
That had to be fucking perfect!
I'm not perfect like you!
I'm sorry!
That's my last heal!
You fucker!
I can't be perfect!
Look at you!
You take my friends!
You take everything!
What more do you want from me?!
What more do you want?!
You already have everything!
I can't live with it!
Oh my god.
He took my frames!
He took my graphics!
He took my immobilized!
What more does he want?!
He wants your HP.
Rose trash talking you.
You're not him.
It's time to show pretty boy you really are.
We're not even the same species!
Content warning.
Thank you with the super chat.
Thank you.
We're not...
We're not even the same species!
How can I be him when I'm not even him?!
I'm over here.
Where did my...
Where's my tornado going?!
It's over now.
I'm gonna go in there and go home.
I... I forgot to lock in from... from my misery.
Bro, just bring- Bro, please, just get this over with.
Bro, please, please, why are you fucking- Why are you playing with your food?!
That's so... the fact that he like looked at me too after.
Why did he have to play with the food after too, Chaos?
Thank you for the five kiboshibs.
Thank you.
Okay, this time.
This time it will be different.
This time it will be different, guys.
Okay.
Okay, this time it doesn't count.
This is the real third try.
Okay, now.
I locked in.
Come on, head over.
That's fucking right.
I know you want to.
That's fucking right, you bitch, you whore.
God, that's right.
That's fucking right here.
Now what you gonna do, you whore?
That's fucking right.
You might be beautiful, but you have 20,000 versions of you?
I don't think so.
That's right.
It's not just about the looks.
The ladies also want 300 versions of me.
That's right.
I can compensate via other means.
Great.
What I learned is I just keep running.
Just keep running.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
It's fine.
Big baby!
That's fucking right!
Big baby works!
Now it's whip time!
I don't care about your fucking giant axe.
Okay, I care about that, though.
That tiger is scary, though.
But I still don't care about your giant axe.
Get over here!
Fucking unchanged right now!
That's right!
That's...
Oh, ow.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
Electricity.
It's time for your appointment, Erlon.
It's time for your fucking appointment!
Just because you think you are too beautiful for this, nobody is too beautiful for the fucking whip!
Okay, we're fine.
Oh, nice.
Okay, nice.
We dodged that.
Oh, shit!
Okay, we almost dodged that.
How?!
Alright.
Let's follow here.
I'll reload.
Okay, I...
I don't know how I could miss that because it was right in front of me.
But it's alright.
Not everybody was born like him.
Okay, there's no way he can sidestep this.
I...
There is a way, guys.
There...
There is a way and he proved it just now.
He proved it just now.
Okay, nice.
Oh, fuck.
Not nice.
How?!
There we go.
Ha, you didn't see that, did you?
Oh, alright.
I saw that, though.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
We're okay.
Dodged.
Oh.
Okay, he...
He didn't need to dodge that.
He absolutely didn't need to dodge that, but that's okay.
Alright, nice.
He didn't parry!
That's right, you're not perfect!
He can bleed!
He's...
He's not as perfect as you think he is!
Thank God!
Okay.
Yeah.
There you go.
Okay.
He...
He did the thing again.
That's okay.
I don't know what to do when he does that, but that's okay.
Whoa!
Maybe go run up to them?
So, like, he can't look down?
Haha!
You can't look down if I'm behind you!
That's right!
Where am I?
I'll never tell!
Oh.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
What do I do here?
Ah!
No!
I did it!
Oh, yeah.
Staff spin.
The move I never use.
It's been...
Finally, after 20 years.
We...
After 20 years, we can finally use the staff spin.
I forgot this move existed.
Not gonna lie.
Chat forgot about this move's existence.
All right.
Alright, okay, we figured it out.
We figured it out.
The sun is a powerful laser.
Alright.
We figured it out, guys.
We figured it out.
It's time.
Pornado!
I locked on too, so he's gonna...
Come on.
That's fucking right.
I know you wanna walk into this.
That's right, bitch.
Bitch.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Here!
I'm gonna show you what I'm made of.
That's... Monkeys, please.
Please be faster.
Monkeys, I need...
Monkeys, please.
I need you to... Monkeys, I see one of you just standing there!
Why are you healing?
He didn't even hit you back!
The whisper.
I saw it, then what if I'm healing?
But it's like, why do you need a heal?
Wait, where did he go?
He didn't even hit back yet!
So there was no point in healing there!
There's actually no point...
There's no way to side...
Alright, there is a way sometimes for him to sidestep.
And I figured out...
There was a way for him to do it.
Okay, nice.
Oh, nope.
Haha, whatcha gonna do now?
Now that I am a...
Now that I'm a horse?
Now that he's also a...
No!
Oh, there we go!
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Untransform now!
That's right.
Oh, you think I'm scared of you?
I'm hot too now.
Oh, okay.
But like, he still hits really hard.
That's right.
Now the ladies find me hot as well.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Everything is...
Okay.
I think I can do hits here.
Woo!
It's okay.
Oh, not okay!
Not okay!
Okay.
There we go.
We're fine.
We're not fine.
Oh, pow!
Pow!
No!
Please!
Please, I'm lazy!
Oh, god.
Okay.
We gotta hydrate.
Okay, I know like...
He parries if I hit too much.
So I'm gonna try to make sure not to parry.
No!
It stuck his spear in me!
Come on!
Oh, it's somebody's birthday!
Guys, give me a sec!
When I die, I'll sing you happy birthday!
Cause we all know we're not winning this fight!
We all...
I can tell this...
We're not winning this one.
This round.
I can so tell.
I don't know his patterns fully yet too.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, yeah.
No, this is not the it.
I'm still trying to download him.
Oh, my god!
I don't know his attack patterns!
It's so fucking weird!
No!
His what?!
I knew he isn't!
His pattern is such a fucking weird pattern!
There's no way!
Okay, there is a Okay.
That's fucking right.
What?!
You don't have a shield!
That's illegal!
You're just gonna...
Okay!
Where are they?
Oh, there you go.
Okay, I was like, where the fuck are they?
Like, okay.
Okay.
Alright, he's gonna do that thing.
What's the...
Okay.
I'm fucking...
I let go my finger!
I...
I let go!
I fucking...
I let go for one frame!
That's actually crazy!
I can't believe!
Okay.
RainbowCloud, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Today is my birthday!
Can I get a song, please?
And thank you, of course, Rainbow!
Thank you for your favorite super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Rainbow!
Yeah!
I can't believe I let go I let go like one second, and then I accidentally like fucking...
I...
Oh my god!
I'm so fucking stupid!
I...
Holy shit!
That's actually crazy that just happened!
I can't believe it!
Why?
Why am I...
Why am I like this?
Why?
Oh my god!
Wow!
How did you... I'm the real monkey!
There's like 200 of us!
Where is he?
Okay.
That's right.
That's right, I run straight.
You guys can't get me.
That's fucking right.
Oh yeah!
I got the horse again!
Now, nay for me, Erlang!
Oh!
Okay, now, nay for me, Erlang!
You think I'm scared of you?
The ladies love me just as much as they love you now!
Oh shit!
Hey, that's not fair!
That's fucking right!
I have the power of electricity on my side!
Erlang!
You might have won 90% of the fights in Journey to the West, but this time it'll be different.
Because this time I have a monkey and a horse by my side.
Okay.
That's good.
It's gonna be different, guys.
Okay, not now.
Now it's gonna be different, guys.
Now it's gonna be different!
Right here!
Oh!
Not here yet!
But like, right here!
Right here!
It's gonna be different here.
What the fuck!
Oh shit!
Okay.
What?!
That's illegal.
That was an illegal move, right?
That is such an illegal move!
I refuse to believe that is a...
that the referee didn't see that.
Like, I'm pretty sure...
I'm pretty sure he bribed the ref...
WHAT?!
I'm pretty sure he bribed the ref.
There's no fucking way.
In the rules, he's not allowed to do that.
And he turns into an eagle!
Okay.
And he pokes!
It's not in the regulations!
I literally need... what?!
I literally need wood!
Erlon, please!
Oh my god...
He's...he's killing me right now isn't he?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, but like, there's no way he dodges this.
Yeah.
Okay, thank God.
Okay.
Thank god, I was going to be worried that he was going to die.
It felt like he was.
At that point.
Sometimes I don't know when I can use...
Okay.
Oh no, it's happening again.
It's happening again.
Okay.
It's happening again, guys!
It's happening again!
Okay.
Where is he?
Wait.
Oh, that was an accident.
Where is he?
Oh.
Oh, this is bad.
I ran...
This is so bad.
I had a feeling it was going to be bad.
I had a feeling.
Horse time!
What?
Oh, we transformed!
That's fucking right!
I still have the power of the horse!
Alright.
Oh, thank god for the invincibility frames on horseman.
Thank god.
What the fuck, though?
What the fuck?
Stop!
Just stop!
Stop doing what you're doing!
No way.
There's no way.
God damn it.
What does this do?
I forgot what that does, guys!
I forgot what that does!
Okay.
Okay!
Oh god, okay.
No!
Wait!
What does this do?!
I swear!
Are you fucking...
Fucking...
Oh my god!
It just never stops!
It just...
That's the fun secret, Doki!
It never fucking stops!
You...
No way!
No fucking way!
Please.
Oh, thank god.
God had mercy on me today.
God actually gave me mercy today.
It was like...
The dread.
And I'm like, you finally answered my call.
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god!
Are you fucking kidding me?
I hate him so much!
Oh!
Oh please!
You have twenty hundred swords!
How much more do you want?!
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna make it here.
It's over.
It's so over.
I...
No more heals, guys!
Goodbye!
What a way to go!
A bit more.
Oh my god!
It was so close!
Okay.
I think...
I have more chi, I think.
To power up my...
Wait, okay.
What gives more chi, guys?
What gives more chi?
I think we need...
Okay, we don't need immobilize.
Immobilize fucking sucks.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Uh...
I'm gonna get rid of immobilize.
That fucking sucks.
I'm gonna fucking get rid of all of you.
Okay.
Uh...
I wanna use...
Launcher's...
Strike...
What gives chi?
I need a no.
I need to get it so I can have the fan.
My fan is building up too slow.
Is there anything that gives me more?
Rock parry spell?
Does that...
Guys, I'm not gonna parry.
Guys!
Guys, I'm...
You know damn well I'm not gonna parry, guys.
What if I put it all in critical hit?
Critical hit.
Okay, critical hit.
And then attack.
Okay.
Critical hit and attack.
There we go.
And then...
Someone said there's like...
Uh...
Let's see...
And the chi spirit.
Chi spirit.
What is that?
Someone said the golden...
Okay.
Upon critical hits, defeat and defeats grants a small amount of chi.
I need all four.
No!
But my...
My armor is so cool!
But my armor is so cool!
It's like, look at how little defense this is!
Look how little defense!
We need time to use...
Say goodbye to the trip.
Wait, my critical rate is 4%?
So your point... Are you serious?
How do I up my critical hit?
It's drip or drown.
Wait, how do I up my critical hit?
Oh, drinks?
Okay.
Which one is it?
Different staff?
Modified sip?
Okay.
Alright, we gotta go back to monkey then.
Alright,
we gotta go back to monkey then.
Brew and soak.
Oh, I can brew there?
Cat B.
I think I have Cat B.
Don't I?
There's a crit chance in talents.
Okay guys, it's backseating.
We gotta get rid of the pretty boy.
Nothing can be prettier than me.
We can't let the pretty boy win.
There's only one pretty monkey here.
Okay, brew.
Essence.
Increases the next attack.
Increase...
Which one is it?
Oh!
Okay, there.
We just get this.
And then, what do we have for soak?
Wait, what do we have for soak?
Laurel beads.
And...
B mountain.
Okay.
Laurel...
Okay, we'll get that.
Laurel.
And then, is there a critical hit?
Oh, there you go!
Oh wait, that's poison.
Nevermind.
Dodge for a short amount.
There's none.
Oh!
Okay.
Uh...
Tiger relic soak?
I don't think I have that.
Tiger relic.
Tiger tea.
There's a soak that buffs.
I have burn.
I need tiger.
What the fuck is tiger balm?
How do I get tiger?
How do I get tiger balm?
You need death stinker and clear it to rub.
In chapter two?
How do I get that in chapter two?
No, I know what Wait, I know what tiger balm is, but I was like...
I thought it was in game.
I thought you meant it's in game.
I was like...
I'm assuming you're talking about in game stuff!
Stop!
Okay.
Where?
Grand chamber.
Wait, where the fuck is secrets?
Wait, that's the sand.
I'm already...
I'm so out of it.
Where was... Okay, it's the new west.
Okay.
I'm so over it right now.
I'm so fucking over it.
This fucking guy.
He took my frames.
He took my life.
Many times.
I don't
know what else to do.
He has everything.
He even has the celestial core.
He took everything from me.
He took my tiger palm.
And now I have to wear some fucking ugly ass gear.
I have to wear this ugly ass fucking...
It's so ugly.
I don't want to use my... I don't want to upgrade this.
I don't want to upgrade this.
No.
Okay, let's see.
Critical hit chance 70%.
Wait, how come I can't get this?
What the fuck?
How can I get this?
Can I craft this?
Why not?
Because it's so ugly.
My drip.
But like...
I just want to look cool.
Okay, we gotta grab this, I guess.
And then...
And then we craft this.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, this is...
10% critical hit chance?
But it's 90.
Wait, is this a better one?
But I want to look cool.
Okay,
which one?
Reignite sparks.
Okay, which one?
This already have it.
Modern creases.
Where's my crit hit?
Wait, don't I have crit hit?
Oh.
Okay.
What do I not need?
I'll put that here.
And then...
Okay.
What do I not need?
Live with it.
Yeah, but when he like...
When I immobilize him.
He fucking...
He just beats my ass.
He fucking beats my ass.
Every time.
Okay, take out pillar stance.
Okay.
Wait.
And I'll put more crit chance.
Alright.
There we go.
We should be good now.
How much?
I have two more guys.
Keep the first?
Oh no, I did.
See?
I have the first one.
I mean, I'll just...
Help?
Oh yeah, I have one on pillar.
Put in damage?
Okay.
And the staff spin.
What the fuck do I need for staff spins?
Okay, here we go.
Wait, I don't think I used...
Did I not...
Oops, that's not what I wanted.
Where's staff spin?
Here.
Okay.
Thrust, okay.
Thrust tab.
Okay.
It's thrust tab.
Alright, this is it.
This might not be it.
Where am I?
Okay.
This might not be it.
I look so ugly now.
I look so ugly.
Okay, yeah, I have crit hit.
I need to max out spin?
Guys, what do I not need?
What do I not need?
I don't know what I don't need, guys.
I don't know.
I mean, I don't have anything on either of these.
Take off the thrust stance?
Wait, somebody said thrust is good.
Thrust or smash.
Okay, we're gonna go with...
We're gonna go with thrust in.
Wait, I need to go back.
I forgot I can't do it here.
Okay, where's my stride?
There it is.
Alright, cut.
What happened to you, Wukong?
You had such good drip.
Do you wanna win or not?
Alright, let's see.
Yeah, but I wanna look cool while I'm winning.
Cool though.
Okay.
I don't have enough.
So I'll take it off this and put it in here.
There we go.
Alright.
I wanna look cool.
But I'm gonna beat him up.
Alright, here we go.
This is it.
Like, he has everything.
All I had was my drip.
Now I have nothing.
Stop it.
All I had were my cool-ass drip.
And now...
Now I don't have either.
Stop it.
What the fuck?
How did you run away from that?
What?
I should have hit him.
Why did I hit him?
He actually fucking ran away from my tornado.
That's not fair.
How did he do that?
How the fuck did he do that?
Okay, that's fine.
Oh shit.
Shit.
Alright.
Now I know what...
Oh my god, bro.
I didn't...
I didn't realize he was done.
What the fuck?
Horse time.
Horse.
Whip.
That's fucking right.
Oh, you bring a tiger?
That's right, you missed.
Bitch!
You can't miss a whip, though!
You can't miss a whip!
Yeah?
That's fucking right.
Five o'clock appointment.
And your six o'clock appointment.
You booked the whole night, man.
Man, you seem fucking stressed.
Booking the whole night?
Okay.
I still don't know when to time this.
I don't know how to time that.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm so confused.
Guys, can you tell I'm confused?
Can you tell?
Is it noticeable?
Oh, my God.
Win!
Shit!
Yes, that's freaking right!
Oh, thank God.
I'm so happy.
I got the win.
I got the...
Never mind.
No win, more win.
He said no win.
I was like, you're right.
You're so right.
You're so... Oh, my God.
How dare I thought.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I don't know what to do.
Oh, you can sidestep my poke?
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
We're fine.
Okay, I need a heal, though.
So I'm not that fine, though.
Spin, spin, spin.
Okay.
Someone said spin, but I don't know if it's actually working.
I don't know.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I don't know if it's actually working, guys.
Oh, no.
Please stop.
That's right.
Baby.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Now it's the children.
Now it's two of them.
Whoo.
If I'm underneath him, he can't see me, but I also can't see anything, too.
It's so weird.
Wait.
Am I spinning?
I am.
Okay.
Poke.
Oh, okay.
I didn't poke anything.
Okay.
That's fine.
I don't need to poke anything, I guess.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Please give me time.
Win.
That's right, bitch.
I'm the kid you made fun of in high school.
Oh, what?
What?
Oh.
Okay.
Bye.
That's right.
You're gonna regret this.
I'm gonna regret this.
You're right.
How dare I?
Okay.
You can fight.
Oh, my God.
No, please.
Let me heal at least, and then you can do whatever the fuck you want.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Nice dodge.
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
That is a-okay.
I have this.
And I can do...
Oh, I cannot do that.
He's...
He can stop.
I...
Why?
I guess not.
You're right.
Oh, you're so right.
You're so fucking right.
Oh, please.
I don't know.
Win.
No!
Please!
You have everything!
Let me have this!
Let me!
Oh!
Okay.
Let me have this!
You literally have everything you ever wanted in life!
They love you!
Oh, my God!
I don't have magic anymore, guys!
I can't immobilize him!
Oh, my God!
I don't have enough magic!
My thing only increases my chi!
Oh!
Oh, my God!
The fuck?
The Apramana Bat Spirit?
Okay.
I know I could just walk back.
I did that!
You serious?
Okay.
I know I could walk back, guys.
Alright.
I need... What?
You should check if you have the Bat Spirit.
I do have it.
Okay.
What is it?
Where is he called?
Aquamarine?
That's a rock.
Turtle Treasure?
The fuck is it?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is!
This guy?
Okay.
Reduces the cost.
This guy?
Oh, Apramarine.
Sorry.
Apramana.
Sorry, I said it wrong.
Okay.
Alright, it's time.
I have so much money anyway.
Never mind.
I'm sorry, baby.
I know you're...
You've been with me since the beginning, but everyone's telling me to ditch your ass.
Everyone...
Everyone is telling me to ditch your ass, but you've been with...
Just know that I didn't...
I didn't...
I didn't mean it.
Just know that I didn't want to.
I...
Just know that I didn't want to, baby.
I did it out of...
Not consensually swapped off you.
I was peer pressured because I'm weak.
Just know that it was peer pressured.
Oh, shit!
How the fuck do I use this thing?
I didn't enjoy it.
I cried when I...
A tear fell down when I had to swap it.
And Oh,
shit.
It's not...
God damn it.
I forgot to rest up.
Don't worry, I'll bring back Big Baby.
I'll bring him back in the final boss.
We just gotta beat up Erlon.
Just had it too good for too long.
He's had it too good for too long!
He has everything!
I have to!
Big Baby, I just had to!
There's no way he hits me.
I need to figure out the range.
Okay, okay, restart.
Please!
Stop playing with your foot!
Just get this over with!
Please!
Stop taunting me!
He fucking taunted me!
That's so fucked!
I can't believe he did that.
He had to monologue.
Alright, here we go.
He took my frames.
He took my drip.
And now he took the baby!
What more does he want?
He even took the baby, chat!
He fucking took the child!
Okay, now this has to be the range.
This has to be the range, right?
Here we go.
Okay.
Oh my god, it is.
It's actually the range.
Then what, do this?
Why do I spin so slow?
Shit.
Okay.
Is this a skill shot?
Oh, I did it!
Yes!
Yeah!
Oh!
Oh, I had to walk forward?
I had to move too!
Eya, why did you take so much?
Oh my god, you used that already?
I can't believe he would make me walk.
That's so fucked.
Oh god, okay.
He would also make me walk too.
Alright, there you go.
Oh, I win again.
That's so good for me.
Where is he?
Oh shit, there he is.
No way.
I...
Okay, thank god.
Okay, I was gonna...
I was gonna be so sad.
Oh shit.
Getting hit by the wind.
Nice.
There you go.
What more do you want from me?
Okay.
Now I have to do cardio because of you!
Fuck you!
He forced me to do cardio!
Okay.
Oh my god.
No, no!
I accident drank!
No!
Oh no!
Oh my god!
I'm stopped!
Oh fuck!
What you gonna do?
I'm a fucking rock now.
I'm the slowest fucking rock.
That's fucking right!
What you gonna do?
Does he not acknowledge me as a person when I'm a rock?
That's so fucked!
Wait.
He doesn't see me as a person.
He doesn't see me as a person!
That's so messed up!
It's just a rock!
Not real to him!
Win!
That's so fucked.
He hates rocks.
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Skill!
That's fucking... Wait, wait, it doesn't... Okay.
Okay, it didn't work.
Guys, how come it stopped working?
Guys, why did it stop?
Guys, I thought...
Okay.
I missed?!
That's...
What do you mean I missed?!
Oh god.
Oh, he doesn't like it.
He gets increased resistance?!
What more does he want?!
What do you mean he gets increased resistance?!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I don't know how to dodge that yet!
I don't know how to dodge my whole thing!
That's so fucked.
He like...
He's basically like the golden child!
He's him.
Win cannot be like him!
I wanna be him too!
Oh no.
What is that?
Oh, it's the doubles!
I'm just gonna... I'm gonna heal.
I'm just gonna be here.
Yay!
He doesn't see me!
Okay.
Alright.
I don't know when to actually spin so I'm just gonna do this now.
Just in case.
Oh god.
Oh!
Spin!
No, I don't heal!
Oh god, you fucking idiot!
You fucking...
You fucking idiot!
That was a mistake, guys.
I... I did not mean to do that.
No!
No, no!
Oh, he grabbed me!
What?!
I don't have... I don't have it anymore.
No!
Rock!
Guys, it's over.
I mean, what is he gonna do?
Shoot me?
Okay, he...
Your thing sucks.
Your thing fucking sucks.
Look at that.
It does nothing to me.
Big rocks coming over.
That's fucking right.
Big rock is coming over.
This is what you get.
No, I'm definitely... I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
I... I'm literally like... I'm literally one HP, guys.
He fucking dodged everything.
It's actually crazy how much he dodged.
Oh!
There's no point in me trying to fucking play this.
I'm literally one.
Oh, my God!
Oh, God!
Oh, and he sidestepped that.
Yeah, fuck me, I guess.
Oh, my God.
This is the closest we've ever got, though.
Is that fair?
How come I keep missing, he can't?
Why is he mom's favorite child?
I wouldn't be a favorite child.
He has... he has the frames.
He has the looks.
He has the power.
He has a tiger.
He has an eagle.
He has the drip.
Like, what do I have?
I don't even have shoes.
I...
I don't even have shoes!
He's just him.
I don't even know the range for this stupid-ass ability.
Oh, my God, he's literally so low!
Okay.
There's no way.
There's no way he sidesteps this bitch.
There's no fucking way you sidestep this, you fucking bitch.
You whore!
You're such a whore!
Wow!
I have to use the wind again!
Because I didn't get the second phase!
I hate you.
Nobody loves you.
Nobody fucking loves you!
Hi!
Hehehe!!
Stop calling me small monkey!
I'm almost the same age as you!
I don't actually think so, but like, I like to think I am.
Oh, my God, it's so fa... Oh, my God, he fucking resisted it!
Okay...
I could have used the rock.
I just realized that.
You're right.
I'm sorry.
I'm special.
So bad at reading instructions.
All right.
Weeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee spin!
What you mean he absorbs it?
Let him absorb it!
Weeeeeeeeee!
Weeeee!
The bee fucking spin on you!
Get over here!
Oh shit!
Okay, he doesn't like that.
Whoa!
Okay, that's fine.
Poke!
Here we go.
Weeeeee!
Eh!
What?!
It's not fair!
Is anything fair in this world anymore?
I'll just wait.
You can just stay there, I don't fucking care anymore.
SPIDE!
Get over here!
Guys,
I don't know.
Guys, I don't know.
I feel... I feel very...
I feel very fucking vulnerable right now.
Spin... spin... spin!
Spin!
Shit, okay!
Okay, it doesn't matter!
Wow, he doesn't know where to breathe!
That's right!
Okay.
That's fine.
Spin...
Shit, okay.
That's fine.
Oh, you bitch.
You're a bitch.
But he loves you.
Oh, fuck!
He only likes you for your looks.
That's right.
I have a personality at least.
Everybody only talks about your looks.
But no...
I'm sorry!
Fuck!
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ, bro.
Please let me...
Okay, that's fine.
Come on!
Please let me poke you!
Yes!
Thank you!
I really appreciate that one thing you gave me!
I know!
Oh god.
Okay, but what if I do this?
And he absorbs it.
That's what...
That's fucking right.
It's rock time!
You might not acknowledge me as a person!
But I shall SMASH!
SMASH!
Get over here!
That's fucking right.
Whoops, sorry.
I got a little finger hungry there.
Smash!
I'm rolling over!
SMASH!
Alright.
And then the last smash.
That's fucking right.
Win!
Oh, why am I using win?
I'm sorry!
Oh god, okay.
Guys, I don't know why I used win.
I got so fucking excited.
Guys, you don't understand.
I actually got...
I got way too excited.
Oh shit.
Guys, that was a mistake.
I wasn't...
I didn't mean to actually use the win.
I...
I got so excited.
I got lost in the sauce.
I got so lost.
I saw...
I was like, whoa, I have the attack now?
And then I was like, whoa, I'm gonna use that.
It's gonna be so funny.
Everybody will think it's so fucking funny when I use it.
Oh...
Oh!
It's fine.
I'll just...
heal.
Alright, nice.
Whoa!
Wow!
Guys, I don't feel so good.
Well, I wanna poke too.
Oh shit!
Okay, never mind.
I guess I don't poke.
Wow!
Slowest fucking axe through of his fucking life.
Okay, nice.
Oh fuck, not nice.
Not nice, not nice.
Not nice at all.
Okay, but what is it?
Are you serious?
How does that not hit?
How does he absorb every fucking...
Okay.
Alright.
It's fine.
Oh!
Guys, I don't know anymore.
I don't...
Oh my god!
I don't know anymore!
He's doing lots of...
There we go.
Alright, there we go.
That's fine.
It's fine.
He's just...
We're just gonna watch...
We're gonna watch him a little bit.
And then...
Oh, he moved away!
Guys, it's not fair when he moves away, guys.
I hate...
Oh god, he wants me to spin again.
Spin, spin, spin, spin.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Okay.
Whoa!
I'm so scared.
I'm so scared!
What?!
Okay.
Rock time!
It's rock time!
That's right!
I have right to win!
Me too!
I have my rock rights!
You might not see me as a real person!
But my chat does!
He's just laughing at you.
What?!
How do I not?
Okay!
I don't know how that...
didn't fucking work, though.
Oh god.
Oh my god!
Okay!
Shit, I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
Oh my god, he healed again!
This is my last healing!
No!
It's over!
Okay.
Oh shit!
No!
God!
Stop!
No!
We were so close!
It was the closest we've ever been!
Gaming, thank you for the 50 gifted chips!
Thank you!
We were so close!
Okay, we got the strat down.
We got the strat down, guys.
Alright, it's time!
This is what we've been saving for!
This is it!
Okay, where is the...
Okay.
Guys, this is it.
This is exactly what we have been saving for this entire time.
This is it!
We've been saving!
This is our moment!
We figured it out!
We...
It gives me back my mana!
I want my mana!
Where's my mana?
Okay, this is it.
I'm gonna take all the drugs.
Wait, do I even have revive?
There's no mana restored!
Okay, that's fine.
We'll just have...
The one medicine we're gonna take would be this.
This is the one!
Alright.
It never existed.
Okay, this is it.
We've hoarded for this one moment in life.
This is what we've hoarded.
Alright, let's see.
Upon use, instantly recovers full HP!
This is it.
This is exactly what we've been waiting for!
Okay, is it this?
Okay.
Alright.
Do I have to drink this before I go in?
Okay.
No.
We'll save this.
I'm still hoarding that.
I'm gonna hoard this one last time.
I'm gonna hoard that.
Alright, there we go.
We'll drink all of this.
Okay.
What did I use?
Okay, long aura amplification.
Alright.
You don't understand.
What have I needed for Wukong 2?
You don't understand!
This is gonna be so important, guys.
This is it.
This is finally it.
We've hoarded our drinking pills for this exact time.
This exact moment in time.
Okay, this is... Okay, I'm gonna drink this now.
And then I'll drink this.
And then...
Boom.
There we go.
Wait, I fucked up.
Wait, I... Oh, I fucked it up.
I was healing.
I pressed R!
My face!
I can't.
Please stop talking.
I need a reset.
I... I...
I pressed R and I missed the tornado.
Everything that went wrong went wrong.
I...
I drank twice.
I was so used to pressing R, guys.
You don't understand.
Okay.
Okay, now...
Now thank god I didn't eat the...
Thank god I didn't eat the pills yet.
Okay.
Alright.
I didn't waste it, guys.
Because I didn't even use it.
I didn't even...
I pressed R instead of Q.
Oh my god.
I pressed R and drank my heals instead.
But this time...
This time it'll be different.
That's fucking right.
Hurricane time.
That's fucking right, you...
bitch.
You fucking whore.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna spin!
Yeah, what you gonna do?
Nothing!
I'm fucking heading over and spinning again!
Spin!
That's how you go!
Okay.
Alright, we're fine.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
We're gonna keep spinning.
We're gonna keep spinning!
Where is he?
No!
He fucking hit me!
That's okay.
I still... I move first.
Oh my god, I still move first.
Thank god.
That's... Thank god.
Spin!
Oh, thank god!
Okay.
Okay, everything is okay.
But he's so far, but I can still spin.
I can still spin to win.
I can... Oh!
It's okay.
I can still spin to win.
He doesn't know where I am.
Spin!
Keep spinning!
No!
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Everything will be fine.
I don't remember what that does.
Okay.
Oh no, he absorbed it.
That's so fast.
That's so fucked.
That's so...
Okay.
Where is he?
Okay, he's right here.
What the fuck?
This is the first time it's ever hit me!
Oh, he's hacking as well!
I've never had an issue with this before!
Okay.
Oh god.
That was so close.
That was actually...
Spin.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's so fine.
We're so okay.
Freeze!
Spin!
Spin like your life means anything!
Wukong!
You matter!
Oh!
Rock!
Whoa!
Please, Wukong!
You so matter!
Oh god!
Rock!
Oh!
Okay, that's fine.
I'll just stay here.
That's fine.
I'll just...
I guess I'll just stay here.
That's...
That's okay.
I'll just...
I'll just AFK until it's over.
It's my turn, bitch.
It's fucking my turn.
That's fucking right.
That's my turn, you whore.
You think you're handsome?
Not so handsome now as I bash your head in.
That's fucking right!
No plastic surgery's gonna save you now!
Oh god.
Oh, please.
This is not fair.
Wow!
Little monkey!
No!
How could you tell?
How far can you go?
Oh shit!
Okay, that was my bad.
I got cocky there.
I admit.
I actually got way too cocky there.
I definitely...
Oh my god.
No!
Okay.
Oh, thank god.
He's monologuing.
Guys, he's monologuing.
I have a chance.
He's monologuing now.
Thank god.
Thank god he's monologuing.
Thank fucking god.
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, that is not fine.
That is not fine now, guys.
Wow!
Oh god.
Okay.
Okay, but what if I drink the damage reduction?
Whoa!
Alright, we're fine.
Oh, he can't do shit now.
Oh god.
Oh no!
No!
Wow!
I didn't see him!
I'm so stupid.
I'm so stupid!
Okay, I didn't see him.
He came out of nowhere!
Why you look at chat?
How did you know?
How did you know I looked at chat?
It was an accident.
I swear to god it didn't mean to.
Oh shit.
Oh, that is so fucked.
Oh, that is also so fucked.
Okay.
He's doing so many acrobats!
Like he should join the Olympics!
Oh fuck.
Okay.
That's fine.
We're okay.
We are actually not okay, but like...
I'm trying my best!
Please.
Oh, are you serious?
Are you serious?
Oh, come on!
Erlang!
Please!
Are you fucking serious?
This is so messed up.
This is actually so messed up.
It's so messed up, Erlang.
Why are you like this?
Who fucking made you like this?
Like, does nobody love you?
Like, nobody actually loves you?
You fucking whore.
Oh my god, you're such a...
You're actually such a whore.
You're like...
You're actually...
You're actually a terrible person.
You're...
You're such a terrible person!
You're such a...
No!
No.
I couldn't heal!
I tried!
I was pressing Q!
I was spamming Q and everything!
No!
I was spamming Q!
Oh my god!
Okay, we got the strat.
We got the strat, guys.
We got the strat.
This is it.
This is...
No, we still have it!
We still have it!
Stop looking at us!
How do I still have the pill?
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
That's fucking right.
Win.
Oh, I can pause?
Oh, it's still... Okay.
Okay.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
I thought I fucked it up.
That's... Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
I got it.
That's good.
That's actually so good.
Thank god.
I thought I actually fucked it up, guys, but...
I didn't actually...
Guys.
I didn't actually fuck it up, guys.
Thank god.
Okay.
Okay, this is fine.
This is so fine.
It's not, but like, I'm just...
It's not, but like...
I need somebody to believe in me.
Okay.
Get over here.
Alright.
Spin time.
Spin!
Okay, guys.
Spin again!
Keep spinning!
We just never...
Stop spinning!
Shit!
Okay.
What if I...
You think I hit those?
Okay, I don't, but I have this.
Okay.
He's an eagle.
I guess we don't have that.
I guess.
Alright.
Goodbye, tornado.
Fuck it...
How did he dodge?
How did he Dodge all that?
I don't understand!
How did he Dodge?
How did he turn into a fucking eagle?
Who let him turn into a fucking eagle?
That's actually cheating!
He fucking cheated!
I didn't lock it!
Oh, I locked it.
Okay, there we go.
I can't believe it!
He turned into a fucking eagle!
Oh my god, I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
Oh, what?!
Okay.
I lost my magic for that, but that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay.
And then I got this again.
And then spin!
Keep spinning!
Spin like it matters!
Okay, we're fine.
Okay, this is okay.
This is okay.
Everything is okay.
Whoa!
Where is he?
Oh, fuck!
Every time!
Please don't attack me.
Please.
What?!
Me in the wind!
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Okay.
Spin.
Keep spinning!
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Every time.
Every time he does that, I just... I don't know.
I don't know.
Spin time.
Spin.
Okay.
That was so close.
Rock, rock, rock, rock!
Turned into a fucking rock!
Okay, it's fine.
He is so racist against rocks.
Alright, nice, alright.
We're walking over.
We're slowly walking over.
Still haven't changed, Erlan.
Still hate rock people.
Thank god.
Haven't changed a single bit.
Get over here.
Okay.
Oh, I'm scared.
Please.
I'm so scared.
What?!
Okay, alright.
I had to do that.
I don't know what happened.
It just stopped working.
I don't know what...
Okay.
Nothing is working out for me right now.
Nothing is working out for me!
Please.
Please don't look at me like this.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, god.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Spin.
Just keep spinning.
Something will work.
Whoa!
Just keep spinning.
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Whoa!
We're...
We're not fine.
But like I like to say that we're fine even though I know we're not.
Does it hit?
No!
It hits but it doesn't matter!
It never matters!
Oh, my god.
I can't see the sword.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
No!
Oh, okay.
No, it doesn't matter either.
Why are you like this?
I feel like you have so much in life.
I'm just a little monkey.
No!
Armor
ready!
Just a fucking monkey!
Okay.
That's good.
I got it.
But I need a heal.
And then just...
Win!
Are you serious?
Are you okay?
Okay.
That's actually not fair.
I'm not gonna lie.
Like...
That should not have been fair.
Okay, who hits first?
Me.
That's fucking where I'm coming over.
I'm coming over.
I'm coming over to spin.
That's fucking right!
Oh, shit!
No!
Spin!
Oh, shit!
We didn't need it, but like...
I...
I was scared.
I know...
I know we didn't need it, but...
You don't understand.
I was so scared.
You don't...
You don't understand.
That's right!
Look it!
You're gonna die now, bitch!
That's fucking right!
What!
Are you fucking...
There's no way.
There's actually no way.
There's no way...
There's no way he just did that...
Guys,
there's no name.
Guys, there's a face too.
There was no name.
No name showed up.
I can't bel- now he decides it was time to fucking not be racist.
Like, what a character development.
What a fucking character development.
Oh my god.
What happened to me?
Last time I threw people.
Oh, Zizu.
Zizu.
Hanzo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh shit, I'm fucking huge.
I'm a big monkey.
Did I do it?
But I'm still in a fight!
Oh, it's Kaiju.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's him!
No!
Yes!
I knew you were ugly on the inside!
I knew it!
You were ugly on the inside, you bitch!
At least I look the same!
Oh, you've been thinking of me?
Bro, what the fuck?
Is this a bromance?
Why isn't that my king?
Oh my god.
He's been thinking of me, guys.
It's the inside that counts.
Exactly.
My inside was the same as my outside.
His inside was so fucking ugly.
I knew he was compensating.
What?
Here comes the four guys.
Can I die?
I can die!
Guys, I get an
attack!
Boom!
That's fucking right.
Oh, that's...
Oh, it's that!
Okay.
Okay, that's right.
Get over here!
Get your ass over here!
Don't worry!
That's right!
You were just playing the instrument!
Beat your ass!
I like how that guy was literally just trying to play on his guitar.
Get over here!
You think you can just play on your guitar like that?
You really think?
That's right.
No music allowed!
No fucking music allowed!
That's fucking right!
He's the bard!
Where's the bard?
Get over here!
I'm fucking gonna beat up the bard!
No fuzz!
No fuzz for you!
Oh, I killed him!
No more bard for you!
No more music!
Oh, you're gonna run away?
No.
I'm gonna target you specifically!
That's me!
No music for you!
No more music in this game!
That's right!
He's fucking dead!
Where's the music, man?
Get over here!
That's right!
Use the music, man!
You're fucking next!
You're next!
I'm canceling the music program!
I'm gonna cancel the music program!
Nobody deserves music in this classroom!
He's running!
Get out!
I'm gonna beat your ass with your own fucking lute!
Yeah!
Music is cancelled!
He just wants to play the guitar!
Leave him alone!
Music has now been cancelled, chat!
He's fucking dead!
That's fucking right!
Bro, he's a dragon now?
Holy shit!
No!
He wanted to play the music donkey!
Why would you do that to him?
He just wants the fuck to play music!
That's fucking right!
Oh my god, the last...
What the fuck?
Oh, he's gone.
What's he doing?
What the fuck?
Oh, you thought that would stop me?
I was born from a fucking rock!
Get out!
You can't break rocks!
We become sand!
And then we'll get into your lungs!
And then you'll die!
That's right!
Oh, the last guy.
Oh, I'm gonna use my special ability on you.
I don't know what this is.
Oh, that's what it is.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Yeah, that's right.
The last dragon in Asia.
Now all dragons are extinct.
I killed the final dragon in China.
Only monkeys allowed.
Wait, what?
I have to do another boss fight?
What you gonna do?
You have no fucking music anymore.
You have no more music, Erlang!
What the fuck are you gonna do?
That's fucking right, Erlang!
Look at you!
Trying to pretend to be a skinny boy!
You're so ugly in the outside!
Wait, I can die.
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
I think I can actually die.
Oh, wait.
No, I healed.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Wait, my HP.
My HP is not going so well, guys.
I got a little worried there.
I got a little worried, guys.
Okay.
Freeze!
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Get down here!
Oh, shit!
Oh, what?
Guys, this is why I don't... Guys, this is what I meant by, like, I don't use, like...
I don't use the rock parry thing.
Guys, I don't think I should be a parrier, guys.
I can't parry!
I can't parry, guys!
I don't know how!
I don't know how to parry, guys!
I don't know how to parry everybody!
How do you parry?
I don't know!
Anyway...
Holy shit.
Why are you so fucking tanky?
Oh, now you don't have a sword.
Become rock when he hits.
Look at you.
You couldn't have learned today.
I missed.
Guys, I never parried in fucking Bloodborne.
I'm never parrying here.
I think I hit, like, one parry throughout this entire fight.
Like, I'm pretty sure.
What the fuck?
He has another sword?
Where's... I have hands!
This is actually bullshit.
I literally have hands.
Like...
What the fuck?
This is so bullshit!
All I have are hands!
Parrying is a crutch.
I beat Orphil Cosmo with no parry.
It's not like... I'm not trying to brag or anything.
I'm just... I just don't know how to play the game.
Oh!
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, god!
Guys, I'm trying to turn it into a rock, but it won't let me!
I'm trying to turn it into a rock, but it's not letting me, guys!
You liars!
You fucking liars!
You told me you can't die!
I fucking played as if I...
I fucking played as if I was damn invincible!
damn invincible!
Oh my god!
I fought as if I was... I thought I thought... because I fought the guys about death or die, guys!
I mean, that's my OG.
I didn't realize you could actually die!
I thought I was invincible!
I...
I legitimately thought I could be...
I could be invincible!
Now I have to try?
What do you mean?
I have to try now?
No!
You never felt it, friend!
You're the only person I'm that special, guys.
What can I say?
I'm so special.
Now I actually have to try.
Oh my god, help!
I'm damn prepared in my fucking life or life!
Why do you do this to me?!
Why do you force me to learn?!
I don't wanna learn!
That's why I'm a streamer!
You gotta learn, but I don't wanna learn!
You're supposed to have...
Guys, I don't know if you've noticed this, but the moment I heard that, like, I don't die, I was definitely not paying attention.
I just kept trying to... I just was left-clicking.
Literally!
I was just left-clicking the entire time because I was like, woo!
I don't need...
I can't die!
That's what the...
I parry.
Click the other buttons too.
I was like, eventually he'll die.
Alright.
Ice tab.
Oh fuck, I thought he was gonna do that thing, you know?
The whip!
Hey, who gave him the whip?!
There we go.
Now I'm parrying!
Now I'm actually parrying, guys!
Now that I know that you can actually die!
Character development.
Right here.
Actual character development.
Not by choice too.
Not by fucking choice.
The character art.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it, Earl.
I hate you.
I fucking hate you.
You forced me to learn to parry.
She's learning at the end of the game.
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Oh!
Oh my god!
I'm so badass!
I was scripted!
Are you fucking serious?
Oh thank god I was scripted.
I was gonna be so mad if it was not scripted.
I was gonna be so mad, Earl.
You don't understand.
You don't wanna make me mad.
You don't wanna make me mad, Earl.
You don't fucking wanna make me mad.
Get over here.
I'm gonna use...
Oh, I can't even use ice.
Oh my god, it doesn't even matter.
You're so fucking weak now.
That's fucking right.
Life steal.
I'm gonna life steal.
That's right.
You can't do jack shit!
I had to learn!
I had to fucking learn how to play this game!
At the last moment!
It only took the final chapter to learn!
She's killing it.
I evolved.
Let's fucking go!
That's right!
You can't do shit!
Another heavy!
And another!
Oh yeah!
Yeah!
You took my frames!
You took the baby!
You took everything I ever loved about this game!
I had to spare!
I had to parry!
I can't use magic anymore!
There we go, we did it.
Nice.
That's right.
You took my drips!
I had to wear such ugly clothes because of you!
You made me learn!
Synapses are firing!
You were so back!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
You made me unfashionable!
I didn't look hip anymore!
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
What is this fight?
I'm just Bunga Bunga Smash!
Phase 4!
What?
Oh shit!
Okay, that's badass!
Badass!
Just stab his third eye out.
That's right Erlong.
And now that I know that you're ugly on the inside.
Now I know I'm...
Now I know you mean nothing.
Your words don't hurt anymore.
Oh!
At least I...
Just how I look on the inside too.
Oh?
Hey, that's me!
Where'd my subtitles go?
That's me though!
Oh!
Forced Doki to learn pairing.
Game of the year.
Hahaha!
Come out!
These are his memories!
It's from the...
Yeah!
And that's the real Wukong.
I'm also the real Wukong too, guys!
Like...
We're both Wukongs!
He even stole my voice?!
Erlong, what the fuck?!
Hahaha!
He even stole my fucking voice!
Are we bros now?
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
He's been helping me this entire time?!
But why the fuck you made me change my outfit?!
Didn't you like...
Doki, you don't understand.
You have to make it look real.
Hahaha!
Doki, you don't understand.
You have to make it look real.
So that people won't suspect.
I needed to learn.
Hahaha!
I can't figure it out.
It's just that Qian Yin doesn't know enough.
In this world, there's no one who can't figure it out.
Why is Baby Buddha so fucking many polygons?!
I swear, every time!
Every time the baby shows up, he takes up all my frames.
Like, first it's Erlong, now it's the baby.
Like...
We need more polygons.
The head must be around.
We did it!
He fucking did all that just to teach me how to parry!
That's so messed up!
Transform into stone money.
Gaining immunity to shock and poison.
Absorb.
Retain axes.
Destined one.
Convert any pre-formation...
Is this a good spell?
What does it take over?
Okay.
Transform is OP.
What a homie.
Taught me how to transform!
I can't believe he taught me how to fucking transform.
Wait, do I have it?
Oh, I have it now.
I was trying to craft it.
The game's like, you have it already, Doki.
What the fuck are you doing?
I couldn't tell.
I've been through so much, guys.
I've been through so much.
I can't tell anymore.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That was fucking hell.
Okay.
Okay, where is my...
Okay, we got that.
Oh my god, thank god.
Now I can look cool.
Now I can look cool again.
Thank god.
I'm back, baby.
I'm cool again, guys.
Forgive me.
Okay.
What do I want?
What do I want to put back?
Oh yeah, immobilize.
I need to put back immobilize, guys.
Oh no, what was my thing?
My thing...
My thing looks...
My thing is so messy.
I don't even remember what I had.
I don't...
I don't even...
This looks so fucking messy.
It's a mess.
We don't need staff spin anymore, guys, right?
Yeah, we don't need that anymore.
We don't need that.
Guys, we don't need that.
Okay.
Uh...
I don't need a spin anymore, chat.
Okay.
No more spin.
And then...
Thrust.
Okay.
We have to get all of thrust?
No spin.
No mana.
We are supposed to play immobilize!
Okay, fuck.
Okay.
We don't need smash either.
We don't need any of these.
We can have immobilize again.
Okay, we need three.
Um...
Uh... What do we not need?
Okay, we can get rid of one of this.
And then we can put it in immobilize.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
Now we can thrust.
And now we can pluck.
Uh...
Oh, yeah.
Apparently the transform is good.
Which one is it?
Is this?
What am I?
The fuck?
Oh, that's me!
Transform into monkey gaining immunity.
Okay, nice.
Build up focus and cast a variety of spells.
Heavy attack.
Okay.
Now I'm rock monkey.
Nice.
Alright, now that we have that...
What if...
Big baby.
Never forget.
Don't worry, big baby.
I told you I'll bring you back.
I told you I'll bring you back, big baby.
Hahaha.
It was just this one time, big baby.
I swear to God.
It was just this one time.
Big baby.
Yeah, that build was... That build was pretty good.
That build was pretty good.
I spinned.
Okay, I wanna grab...
I want the mana.
Uh...
We'll have the mana again.
Okay.
Nice.
See?
Look, this is how...
This is how cool I actually was, okay?
This is...
This is how Erlan's fought.
We got custody back.
After Erlan was like, haha, JK.
It was all a test.
Um, we re-adopted the baby.
He gave me back the kids.
He was like, JK, I never wanted this kid anyway.
It was just to fuck with you.
And then he gave me back the baby.
Didn't Erlan make us kill our wife's friend?
Look, like, it was just a prank.
And, like, as a bro, like, I...
You know, like, you know, as a bro, sometimes, you know, bros like to prank you.
You know?
Wow, this is an open area.
I wonder what's gonna happen here.
Hahaha.
Yeah, as a bro, that happens sometimes, you know?
Sometimes, they're like, wouldn't it be funny if you, like, kill your friend's wife?
And then he's like, bro, I didn't actually mean it.
It was just a joke.
But, like, whatever.
That was pretty funny.
Oh, shit, it's guy with hair!
You nasty slut.
Bro, he doesn't even have a mouth.
How could he slander you?
You're gonna die today!
We love a guy with a hand!
Wait, is he actually gonna help me?
Okay, let's see.
Smash!
Poke!
Oh, my God!
You see that poke?
Big Baby!
Oh!
Boy, Big Baby does a lot of damage.
What the fuck?
That's actually a lot of damage.
Holy shit.
That's crazy.
Oh, my God!
That's also crazy.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
Um, I'll just do Rock Monkey time.
I mean, I have to learn anyway.
That's fucking right.
Smash!
Wait, where are you?
That's fucking right.
Oh, my God, there's so many wheels.
But, wait, where did, where did Drewbucka go?
Again!
Wait, where did he go again?
What the fuck do you mean?
What the?
What?
How did he?
Okay.
That's bullshit.
He left me again?
Doki, it's just a prank on you.
Oh, yeah.
He's like...
He's just pranking you, too.
Wait, does this work?
On him?
Spin!
Oh, it does!
Nice.
It also works on him, too.
Guys, I'm on fire right now.
That's fine.
That's right!
Okay.
Just parry, bro!
Bro, why does he always leave?
This is fine.
I can heal here.
Wait, there's a wheel.
Wait, everything is on fire.
Wait a minute.
This is not good.
Okay, nice.
Haha, you thought that was me?
JK.
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
Okay, that's not fine.
Thrust!
Nice!
Oh, please let me get that heal.
No!
Please let me get that... No!
Please let me get this heal!
Oh!
Guys!
I don't want to use my life-saving pallet!
Oh, shit!
This is okay.
We're fine.
Oh, we're not okay.
What the fuck is he doing?
Oh, shit!
Poke!
Come on, you solo!
Come on!
We just need one, two hits!
Three hits!
Five hits!
Six!
Okay, nice.
He's dead.
We just need seven hits, guys.
That's okay.
We got...
Oh, shit.
I'm flying.
I got to be a bird now.
I swear, Chibaka is so fucking useless.
He always leaves me.
Oh, my God!
Did I break his fucking hand?
Oh, now you're...
Okay.
I got my cloud!
I got
my ride!
I broke his wrist.
Yeah!
Bro, we could have got the cloud together after we killed the guy.
You didn't...
You didn't have to go off and find it.
We could have found it together.
We could have gotten it in time.
We could have done this in 15 minutes.
I still got it!
Okay, we still got this.
Okay, this is...
We got this.
He's gonna...
I got this.
I can call the clouds now.
Okay, nice.
Nice, I can ride the cloud.
Is there anything else here?
Let's see.
Oh my god, fine, go thread.
The one thing I've always wanted.
Wait, where's my curios?
How did I lose all of it?
What the fuck?
Oh, there.
Okay, it bugged out.
I was gonna say, how did I just lost all my curios?
Like, what happened?
I'm like, did I lose it all?
Do I go?
Just go forward?
What the fuck?
The fuck is that?
Guess I'll go over there.
Supreme Celestial Inspector.
Oh, it's him.
He's that guy.
It's a guy I killed.
Reset my graphics.
You guys want...
Oh yeah, since Erlon is dead, we can have better graphics again.
Since he's dead, we can at least enjoy this.
Let's put this back.
Not dead, since we beat him up, we can have this back.
Like, since he... we passed his test.
Guys, JK.
Guess not.
I guess not, guys.
I guess the game was like, no.
There's a boss to get to the final.
And for the cricket, you should use the item that reduces fire damage.
Okay.
Where is it?
This one?
Never mind.
Guys.
Guys, which one was it?
There's too many trees.
There's too many trees, guys.
So, never mind.
The trees are too intense, guys.
Okay.
Guys, I don't remember what we had.
I know.
I mean, the trees are too intense, chat.
We gotta chop down the trees.
We gotta chop down the trees so we can have our graphics back.
Get our frames back, chat.
We gotta get the frames back!
Okay.
I don't remember what we had.
I don't remember.
I don't remember what we did.
Guys, what did we do?
Oh, there he goes.
What was it?
What was it before?
I don't
remember.
I don't remember.
View distance was low.
And then illumination down.
Okay.
What's this?
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
We fixed it.
Guys, I know, I know it doesn't look the best, guys, but like... Oh my god, look at my cloud!
Look at my cloud!
Look at my pixelated cloud!
Holy fuck!
Okay, let's go.
Okay, what the fuck happened to my cloud?
Wait, where did the cricket go?
Where did he go?
It's a PNG cloud.
What the fuck happened to the cloud?
What the fuck did the cricket...
The 8-bit nemesis.
I was too busy fixing the graphics that I don't know where he went.
What happened to the cloud?
I want to just fix the cloud in general.
Um...
Like...
What made it like this?
He saw the cloud.
Okay, we'll keep... We'll stand on our PNG cloud.
The fucking 144p cloud!
Holy shit!
My 144p cloud.
It looks like a sensor.
Jesus Christ, okay.
Um, this place... Where did the cricket go?
Like...
Where did the cricket even go?
I gotta chase him?
Okay, I think he went this way.
Oh my god.
Guys...
Guess there's just too many foliage, guys.
There was a lot of trees.
It's like...
The cricket.
Somebody right-click deleted the cricket.
Where is he?
Which path did he walk to?
You hear chirps?
I don't hear jack shit.
Everything is so blurry.
Sorry, that's my low view distance right there.
Wait, maybe I can fix...
Sorry, this is like phase five of the graphics boss.
This is...
Phase five of the graphics boss.
He walked a different direction.
Guys, I was so busy trying to fix my fucking graphics.
Cricket lives in high gra...
I was so busy trying to fix it.
Okay, is there another boss that's close?
Guys, is there another boss that's close by?
I feel so lost here.
This?
Is that boss over there?
I mean, it's an open area.
I assume so.
It is open.
Oh, I lost a little bit damage there.
I mean, the...
Oh, lang...
Ball ball?
Oh, no!
Not yet!
No!
It's him!
He's back!
No!
Not so far!
Oh, not there!
final frog...
Wait, are you helping me?
Wait, what?
Why are they helping me?
That's right.
Yeah, I didn't expect them to fucking help me.
I mean, I'll take it.
The last frog.
They hate frogs too.
Finally, we can relate!
We can finally relate to each other.
We all hate frogs here.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Oh my god.
He's a rock.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna... we're gonna send more minions in now.
Oh shit, we're gonna send all of them over.
No!
Bang!
Just keep banging.
It'll eventually work.
Bro, what the fuck?
Oh shit.
Okay,
I gotta heal.
I just hear a boom, boom, boom, boom.
No, I just keep hitting the rock.
It just keeps hitting it.
Jeez, the frog.
I'm just fucking... I... I just keep hitting the fucking...
Oh god.
Yay!
I did it!
All me!
All me.
Thanks, man.
I'm glad we both hate frogs too.
I'm glad we're both prejudiced against frogs.
Nice.
And I stole his kids.
First try.
All me.
Nice.
At last, we have something in common.
Like, you know, killing the monkeys, the other monkeys, was not cool, bro.
But frogs?
That's fine.
Frogs is like, free... free real estate.
Is there any, like...
He's got all his children now.
Nobody can have babies.
Now where do I find the other bosses?
Oh, that has to be a boss.
It's a giant hippo.
Okay, I need to find a shrine, though.
On my PNG pixelated cloud.
On my...
I can't.
I... I can't.
This fucking PNG cloud.
Where's the thunder?
Okay, there has to be a shrine here, right?
My sensing cloud.
It's just so good.
Where's the shrine?
This doesn't look like there's a shrine.
It just looks like there's a lot.
It looks great if you squint.
Yeah, but is there a shrine here?
Oh, there is.
It's just...
Oh, there it is.
It was, like, right next to me.
All right.
Let's go to the crocodile or hippo.
Okay, rest.
All right.
We go to the...
We go to the hippo.
I assume the hippo.
Walk forward?
But there's a boss behind me.
Where is he?
Yeah, but I want to kill the hippo first.
Oh, the hippo is just a mob?
I can't believe it.
Not even a real fucking boss.
Oh, he looks so handsome.
Oh, never mind.
He opened his eyes.
Now he looks a little silly.
A hippo grip.
No, it's like a moose gripping.
Oh, it's a deer.
Wait, it's... No, no!
My friends!
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Now I'm poking your ass.
Poke.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I did not mean to poke you.
Oh, JK.
Monkey time.
Monkey smash.
Get over here so I can keep smashing.
Monkey will always smash.
Oh, you're going to start tornadoes?
That doesn't matter to me.
Because I'll still punch you.
I'll punch you in the ass.
That's fucking right.
You think I care?
Whoa.
It's fine.
Oh, shit.
Guys, I forgot to change my relic thing.
I just realized I forgot to change it.
Whoa!
Okay.
What?
What did he do?
That's right.
I'm going to do this now.
Now my monkeys are going to fight you instead.
That's fucking right.
Oh, no.
That's fine.
Oh, that's so good.
Good job, monkeys.
Monkeys strong together.
Monkeys are so strong together.
Monkeys, I need you to hit him.
Wait, what?
There's a phase two?
What?
What does that...
What do you mean there's a phase two?
That's...
Wait, is that you, Buckeye?
Wait, where did you come from?
Oh, now he's going to help me.
Like, I'm just like, where was he before?
Like...
I mean, all right.
I'm not going to complain.
I'm just like, where was he before?
When did he show up?
Oh, now he wants to fucking help.
Like, after I've been, like, crying at him to help me this entire time.
Okay, I need to heal here.
Because I'm poisoned anyway.
That's fine.
I shouldn't complain.
He's, like, at least here now.
He's at least here.
He's...
Don't complain, Doki.
He could have never came back.
At least he finally came back.
Oh, is there another phase?
Oh, thank god!
Oh, you want the help or not?
Where the fuck was he with the frog?
Seppo, wait this time!
The glory's...
You were not even there for phase one!
Why did it rip its skin?
Giga, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The frog was not important enough.
He got the last hit, Doki.
It's his.
Fucking kill stealer.
Oh, shit.
My feet is glowing now.
They're so red!
Oh my god.
Oh, look at his hands.
What's with the tears?
He smoothed out the blood and the blood.
I don't need them anymore.
I know.
He's in the middle of the room.
He's...
I thought there was more to this.
He's dead.
Oh, shit!
Nice!
Oh, I get new armor every boss!
Oh, that's sick!
Oh, shit!
Okay, that's good because the shoes are better than what I had before, I'm pretty sure.
The lotus silk cloud treaters.
Splendid, splendid.
Okay, so there's four main bosses then.
So I can get four outfits.
That's nice that I don't have to walk too far because I have my cloud.
Oh yeah, what about the frog armor?
Was the frog not imported enough?
I put on this fucking fire relic and it never mattered.
Time to collect the monkey drip.
Thank you for the super chat, Marvin.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm going to rest up.
I can't believe it.
Frogs deserve rights to be... Frogs deserve being main bosses, guys.
Where's the frog union to demand that?
Where's the frog union?
Oh my god, 72?
That's actually pretty good.
What curios did I got?
Wait, what was the curios?
What curios?
Oh wait, what is this?
Ignores the enemies for being resistance?
I killed the entire frog union.
You know that?
I still have their kids.
That's not true.
I have their children.
It's not true.
If their kids are in my hand, we can always restart the frog union.
We can always bring it back.
I'm going to put visual effect quality and see if that's the thing.
Oh, okay.
At least we can have visual effect back.
Okay.
Where do we go?
Are you going to raise the frogs?
No, but like...
Like, I don't know.
Okay, no.
Actually, maybe...
I don't know why I keep playing God.
I know what placement this is.
Wait, there's no God.
There's no one.
There's nobody here.
The cricket disappeared.
Where the fuck are things?
Yeah, but I want to fight the mini-bosses.
Wait, what's this guy over here?
There's a guy over here sitting there.
Is he a boss?
Or is he just chilling?
Hello?
There he is!
Oh, my God.
I swear to God.
I swear to fucking God.
If you run away, I swear to God.
I'm going to...
I'm going to fucking...
Where do I hit?
Like...
What?
Where's your weak spot?
I have to go on top of it?
Please, please don't move.
Please, no!
Please, please, no!
Please!
Oh, my God.
I didn't know!
I was so confused.
I was like, where is this weak point?
Okay, now I know.
Now I know.
Clutch.
Clutch your kick.
Oh, shit.
Whoa.
Maybe I should have had fire resistance.
Oh, okay.
I just hold.
What?
What the fuck happened?
I let go for one second.
I actually accidentally lit.
Are you serious?
Oh, my God.
I...
For one second.
That is so bullshit.
Oh, my God.
I just...
I...
I freaked out.
Go there?
Where?
Oh, my God.
Guys, you don't understand.
I'm so lost.
I...
You don't understand.
I'm so confused.
Oh, there was a shrine next to me.
I heard the .
Okay, let's see if we can first try.
Oh, there's dead...
Dead celestial court here.
That means we can be best friends.
We both hate the celestial court.
You told me to be the best friend.
I hate the celestial court.
Oh shit!
Wait, he's gold.
I can use him for... I can use him for good armor.
Gold armor Rhino.
Alright, time to poach this Rhino.
There's no way he's the last of his kind, right guys?
Wait, what?
What?
Oh, what the fuck?
What do I hit?
What the fuck?
Oh, his stomach.
Okay, that's five.
Oh my god, I have to like not be like in his head.
We gotta smack his butt like last time, guys.
We just gotta smack his butt.
Butt smack!
Okay.
Alright, there you go.
Get over here!
Get your ass over here!
How am I supposed to smack you?
Oh!
That's fucking right.
Smack!
You're frozen!
Okay, nice.
Okay, smack.
Alright, that's good.
That's good.
I'm gonna heal and I'm gonna let my bros smack them for me.
Alright, bros, it's your turn.
It's your turn bros.
Don't worry, I'm gonna charge it up.
Oh, he's getting closer guys.
He's getting us so close.
This is a joke by the way, I love animals, but also I'm pretty sure I'm gonna make his fucking horn into gear like
Guys poaching is wrong guys Don't joke about the frogs though.
Fuck the frogs though The frogs I actually mean it The frogs are not a joke
What's he doing?
Wow
Poke okay.
Nice.
Not nice No, not nice.
No No, I wasted it!
Nooo!
No, okay, that's fine No, what the fuck?
That's illegal.
That's actually legal!
Oh shit, okay Guys I have more important things to do right now As much as we would love for me to try the cricket again, I literally have to fucking beat up a giant rhino Are you fucking?
Oh that was sick though, but too bad I missed it That looked so sick though at least That looked sick I wish... I wish I could have I wish that hit though, at least it looked cool But
Okay, nice, I dodged it.
Nice, alright.
Just imagine if it hits.
Nice.
Gryffindor, Doki.
Joshua, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Firmly grasp it.
Ooh, what did I get?
Oh, it's like my original outfit!
Poaching successful.
Guys, it's not poaching when it originally belonged to me.
If anything, the Rhino stole it by existing.
The Rhino stole it by existing.
Technically, it's mine.
Exactly.
Technically, it belongs to me.
It's not my fault that he had to exist.
How dare the Rhino exist.
I know, right?
Fucking stealing my armor and everything.
Where's the cricket?
Oh, he's gone?
Oh, okay.
He's gone.
See?
Yeah, we may not realize that even his... we cannot feel pain when injured.
A heart of gold, lungs of silver, a head of copper, an iron body.
Yeah, I acquired it!
Exactly.
It was mine in the first place.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot to get to the shrine.
Where the fuck is the shrine?
Oh, there it is.
I don't know if this one is better or my... the bull upgrade is better.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Killing animals and bugs.
Animal protection center might think it's abuse.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was mine originally!
It belonged to me!
Yeah, but like, I look cooler.
Yeah, Bull King's one is cooler, guys.
We don't need the... guys, we don't need the critical hit.
We don't... we don't need... we don't... guys, we don't need the critical hit.
We don't need it.
Guys, we don't need it.
Guys.
Yeah, but it... but... but look how cool I am.
Like... like this, though.
Look how cool this is.
Look at this drip.
Oh, my God.
There you are.
I knew you would come back.
I fucking knew it.
Okay.
I did this.
There we go.
Also, I'm pretty sure... I'm pretty sure there's only one of them.
I know!
I'm holding.
I'm still holding.
Let go.
I didn't... I... I didn't realize.
I... I didn't realize!
I didn't... I... I... I thought my stamina...
Guys!
My stamina's...
I thought... I thought I could let go.
Recharge.
I was like, oh, my stamina's going down.
Maybe I should recharge it.
No!
My life saving...
My life has been saved.
Yay!
Oh, I still have it.
Thank fucking God.
There it goes.
I thought... I thought it was...
Oh, my God.
I thought... I thought it's like, you know...
You hold it, but like...
But...
But like, you wait for it to recharge.
It's okay.
Everything is okay, guys.
Alright.
Okay.
What is this guy?
I just want to know who he is.
Is he a friendly guy?
Hello.
Is he friendly?
Is he just watching me?
Oh!
Okay.
He's a tree.
He's a tree anyway.
I hate trees.
That's right.
What you gonna do?
This is your fault.
This is literally your fault.
He was just chilling.
Doki, he's not even a mandatory boss.
He was just...
Yeah, but he witnessed everything.
He saw it.
Guys.
He saw the cricket incident.
No witnesses.
No fucking...
Guys, we can't have any witnesses, guys.
He saw it all.
I know he did.
You can't fucking trick me.
I know you saw it.
I know you saw the whole thing.
I know he saw it.
He literally saw it.
He was there.
I can't let them know.
No witnesses, chat.
No fucking witnesses.
We're awesome.
For now.
He was clapping.
He made fun of me, chat.
He fucking made fun of me too.
He's just a little cat.
I saw him make fun of me.
Okay.
He was clapping.
I don't think he was clapping because he was thinking I was a fool.
Now who's a fool?
Fuck.
There's a shrine on the other side of the rock that he was next to.
Where is it?
He thought I was the fool, but look who's alive.
Behind the stone in some other area.
He was happy for you.
Lies.
He saw me fumble twice.
I guess there was a fucking shrine here.
I didn't succeed.
So why was he clapping?
Why did he clap?
Huh?
Oh, there's a shrine here because fun.
That's exactly why he's not alive.
There's nothing funny about it.
That's exactly why.
That's why baby is no more.
Alright, where the fuck?
Wait, what's this?
What is this?
Water curtain cave?
Should I go up here?
Oh, that's the go here last.
Oh, okay.
Alright, we go here last.
Yeah, I was gonna say this looks like my house.
Is the cricket back yet, guys?
Is he back now?
Guys, where the fuck is he?
Where is the cricket?
Guys, how is the cricket the hardest part of this game?
Like, am I stupid?
I am.
Don't answer that.
I already know the answer.
I already...
Guys, I already know the answer.
You don't have to answer it.
Wait,
I hear the cricket.
I hear him.
Where is he?
I heard...
There he is.
There is this fucker.
So, when do I let go?
Do I just hold it in forever?
Wait, where is he gonna jump?
Cause like, what about my stamina?
Just hold?
Okay, he has to jump.
I know you wanna jump.
Me and my fucking 144p...
44p cloud.
Where he jump to?
Okay, this is it.
This is it.
Now that I know...
that I just have to hold.
nothing can stop me now.
Wow!
That's fucking right!
I'm holding.
This is it.
I should have enough stamina.
Oh my god.
Thank fucking god it's over.
Oh thank god it's over.
Is it over?
Do I keep holding?
What?
I'm dead.
I'm gonna die.
Wait, I'm alive.
Oh my god!
I was like, do I just burn to death?
Wait.
Wait, what the fuck?
That's it!
That's the fucking...
Oh my god.
That was it.
That was literally all I had to do.
Oh my god.
That was the hardest boss in the game.
That's literally the hardest boss.
Holy shit.
Guys, no you can't say that already.
I fucked it up twice.
It was the hardest boss in this game.
Oh my god.
That was the hardest boss in the entire game, guys.
Alright.
The Fintail General.
Gosh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, I'm gonna... Thank you for the very first super chat.
Okay, let's... alright.
No, I wanna look badass.
I don't need my armor.
Guys, it's not about the past.
It's about the future.
It's...
I'm here for the future.
Alright, here we go.
Go back to the swamp?
Where the fuck was the swamp?
Alright, let's see.
The Swamp Shrine?
Oh, okay.
Where did the shrine go?
I...
This map...
This fucking...
Guys, I can't even find the shrine.
Oh, there it is.
It blends in!
It literally...
Guys, you can't judge me.
It literally blends in.
It blends in so much.
Edsel, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
It blends in so much.
You don't understand.
Alright, where is the other boss?
Where is Chupacar?
Oh, is that him?
Oh, there he is!
Woah!
I really gotta puff off my cloud.
What the fuck is that?
It's so tiny.
Woah!
Chupacar!
Chupacar...
Why the fuck was he trying to kill him?
He was just minding his own business.
Wait, am I going to kill him?
Are you serious?
I didn't even consent to this!
Why?
He turned me into a cicada!
Oh my god,
this guy is slashing!
Oh my god, I got bored.
Bro, this is your fucking fault.
He's just trying to chill.
This is your fault!
Oh, I forgot to change my relic again.
God damn it.
I keep forgetting to change my relic.
Okay.
Minions!
Go mini me!
That's right!
Oh shit.
Wait, that was it?
Phase 2?
Wait, what is he?
He's sharpening his fucking hand?
Get bored, bozo.
Thank you for the super chat, John.
Thank you.
Oh, he's using the stomach acid to make it acidic.
Now it's gonna like, poison me or burn me.
Wait, why don't I put my sword into the stomach acid?
It should be the same thing.
Where did my little monkeys go?
Where did...
What do you mean?
They just disappeared!
Like...
Wait, but he got cutscenes.
No!
It's one of those fucking live, like, live cutscenes.
That's so fucked.
I got live cutscenes, guys.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I got live cutscenes.
That's so fucked.
I got live cutscenes, guys.
I can't believe I got live cutscenes.
Oh my god.
That's messed up.
That's so messed up.
This is fucked up, bro.
This is actually so fucked up.
No!
My first sentence!
I'm distracted here!
They're on a lunch break.
I'm on a face-tail.
I died to a bug.
No!
I'm gonna fucking go in your mouth again!
Just spawn me in your mouth!
Spawn me in your fucking mouth!
Just...
Oh, no.
I gotta get eaten again.
He's like, alright, get in my mouth.
Oh, no.
No, you fuck god.
No.
This is not fair.
I did... No, I forgot to change my fucking thing again!
I forgot to change my relic again.
God damn it.
Not again.
And then he ran away.
This fucker, honestly.
I can't believe I got... I can't believe I got live cutscenes.
That's actually so bullshit.
That's so bullshit.
That should not be a thing.
Okay, now I summon my monkeys.
I didn't know it was gonna be a phase two!
I thought I was gonna fucking rail his ass!
Raising.
Okay, now.
Go in, my minions.
Go in.
You know what?
I'm gonna go...
Big monkey tube.
That's right!
There's so many of us now!
That's fucking right!
What you gonna do now?
There's so many of us!
Wait, where are you?
There's so many of us, I'm losing track.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Gotta get out of here.
Oh, we gotta get out.
We gotta get out.
Whoa, he's so fast!
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, he's so fast.
Whoa!
He has 700 movesets!
Nozai!
Thank you for...
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome...
He has 200 million...
Okay, now I remember.
He has so much damage!
Oh, my God!
Okay, more time.
I'm like...
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
Now I remember to change the thing!
Okay.
Which one should I do?
Maybe...
Maybe this.
I don't know.
Which one's better?
The needle or the fan?
Fan?
Okay, we'll try the fan.
All right, tornado time.
Okay, vortex...
Guys, I'm not dying because I enjoyed this, guys.
I know every other boss, it was so easy.
Guys, this is not because...
I'm not purposely throwing, guys.
Like, he's just very strong.
I swear to God.
I'm not dying on purpose, please.
I swear to God, this is not on purpose, guys.
I swear to God.
This is not on purpose.
He's just really strong.
Guys, he's actually very difficult.
What?
He's like this.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Nice, okay.
Phase two.
Guys, please.
Please, I swear to god, this is not intentional.
I swear to god.
Can I get this off in time?
No guys, he's so fast.
I cannot.
Unless...
Oh, I don't even have it.
I forgot to rest!
Guys, not purposely throwing.
I just didn't know I forgot to rest.
I actually forgot to rest.
Smash.
Please.
I need you to keep smashing.
Oh my god, I still can't believe I forgot to rest after swapping!
No!
Whoa, whoa!
Whoa!
Whoa.
Whoa, that's not cool, bro.
That was not cool.
That was not cool at all.
That is not cool at all.
Oh my god!
Okay.
There we go, we did it guys.
I told you guys.
We fucking did it.
Oh, that should be my chest piece.
See, I didn't need the tornado.
Oh my god, is he gonna throw me up?
Ugh!
At least I didn't expand on him.
Oh nice, I got my shoulder pads.
Or my braces.
Okay, I must not smell good.
Not me either?
That's a fucking lie.
I know you're not a vegetarian.
Or vegan.
Wait, is he?
No, but like, in the shows he ate meat.
No,
but like, in the shows he ate meat.
No, but like, in the shows he ate meat.
He is vegan?
Wait, but in the shows!
Okay.
He is now?
Oh, he became one!
Oh, okay.
I didn't realize he became one.
I guess because he's a monk.
Yeah, you're right.
The show is a lie!
But the shows are wrong!
Alright.
Let's see...
No, this is okay because that's stronger than the red one.
Where do we go?
Is there another optional boss?
Wait, wait, I want to kill all the optional bosses!
Alright, let's...
I want to do all of them!
Where are the rest?
If I beat up that giant rock child, I'm going to beat up everybody else.
Okay, no, I'll change the armor during the final.
But like, now that I'm here.
I killed the frog.
There's three more.
I thought the hippo was...
I thought the hippo was just a mob.
There's an optional boss here.
SHK, what?
Yeah, I have...
form, feeling, and choice.
Is that all of them?
I have three.
How do I get the other two?
Oh, there's a small whirlpool.
There's a whirlpool.
That's just...
Oh, there it is!
That has to be a boss right here.
That's right, I know you're alive.
That's right, I know you're here.
Okay.
You're such a fucker.
You're actually such a fucker.
Oh, they'll not show...
She will know.
She won't know.
How will she know?
How is she gonna find out?
Actually, what a fucker.
Trying to bait me there.
Your ass deserves this.
Your ass fucking deserves this, bitch.
You.
My hand was like on the wrong...
move.
Oh my god.
Fuck this.
Yeah, this is overkill, but I don't care anymore.
I don't care.
I don't care if this is overkill.
Fuck you.
Actually...
I'm fucking gonna beat your ass.
That's like you, right?
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Get your ass over there.
You.
That's right.
Fuck you.
I pulled out everything when he was like 1 HP.
Alright, he's dead.
He's fucking dead.
He did not deserve to be alive after that.
And got the cloud.
Dropped it directly down into the...
Oh, okay.
I'll get that.
What if I just jump down?
I can't believe he won't let me jump.
Wait, where am I?
How did I get here?
Oh, there it is.
I was like, how the fuck did I get here?
Instant transmission.
Alright, I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick.
And then I'm gonna...
I'm gonna find the other...
The lizard.
And I'm back.
Or am I?
Okay.
Bite!
Ginger!
Nippers!
Cosmic!
John!
Duck and Alan!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Okay, it was like...
It was in the path here.
This should be it.
What additional bosses do we have left?
Guys.
What key items do I have?
I have...
I have choice, healing, and form.
I have three.
Yeah.
One really big rock, dude.
Where did I get that?
It's this way.
Why the fuck did I get...
Chapter 3?
The last one is in Chapter 3?
How did I miss that?
Alright, we go this way.
It's like down here?
Is it down here?
Is it here?
No?
Where did that come from?
Oh, keep going forward.
Okay.
Oh my god, where am I?
I'm so lost.
Oh, up the cliff.
Okay.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'm so fucking lost.
Holy shit.
Now down.
Oh, it must be here.
Here?
Where is it?
Where is he?
Where's this stupid lizard?
Lizard.
Oh!
Bro.
Oh my god.
Fuck.
Why are they all like this?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god!
That's...
Holy shit!
Holy...
What's hitting me?
Like actually, what's hitting me?
Holy shit!
Jesus Christ!
I can't...
I...
I don't know...
Okay, that looked cool though at least, you know?
At least that looked cool.
Like...
At least...
You know, at least that looked cool, you know?
Like, holy fuck!
What the fuck was I supposed to...
You have two tails?
That's not possible!
Animation team!
What's going on?
What the fuck is this animation team?
What the fuck is this?
Where did three fucking tails come from?
Please tell me those other two of those were your tails.
You're not a hedgehog.
Oh, nevermind.
Nevermind, some lizards...
Nevermind, you're right.
Some lizards have more than three tails.
Two in the front.
It's not his tail.
Sorry, I meant echidnas.
I meant echidnas.
Alright, where's the next boss?
Go left?
Where did I come from?
I came from here.
Okay.
Alright, let's go find the other bosses first.
That's a normal hippo.
That's just a normal hippo.
Oh, on the mountain.
Okay, back to the mountain we go.
You mean this way?
Oh, where the deer was.
Okay.
Alright.
Instant transmission.
Pew!
Alright.
Where I killed the deer.
Travel.
Deer sight.
There it is.
Yeah, just a bunch of regular hippos.
I make sure they're alive so they know that I can show mercy.
Alright, where do we go?
Up to the right of the mountain from the deer.
So right here.
Here.
Right?
This mountain?
Such a kind soul.
Look for a clearing.
Oh, there it is.
There's a fucking...
Oh, that's...
Yeah.
Guys, that rock does not look like...
Okay, I should...
Yeah, guys.
Yeah, that rock.
Yeah, that's...
Oh, okay.
Fuck me, I guess.
Okay, cool.
Maybe win?
Okay.
Nothing works, I guess.
Alright.
I guess...
I guess just nothing works.
I guess nothing works.
I guess I'll just miss everything.
That's fine.
That's absolutely fine, guys.
It's just life at this point.
What's three?
What is the three magic?
What did I do?
I can have multiple?
No, it's just one.
Never mind.
It's me and my bro.
It's me and my...
That's fine.
You know, that's fine.
Two is pretty cool, too.
Just the two...
It's me and my bro.
Me and my clone.
Okay.
Ice!
Oh, shit.
Never mind.
No ice.
Okay.
You go do your thing.
I'm just gonna watch.
Oh, never mind.
I guess we both...
fucking despot.
I guess.
I guess we could... You know what?
We'll do it again.
That's fucking right.
Go me!
Oh, shit.
Guys, please.
What the fuck?
That was three fucking poisons.
Not poison.
Wait, they're all dead?
How?
What?
Damn.
Is that what happened to the other monkeys?
Holy shit.
I don't have to know what happened to the other monkeys.
Oh my god.
Wait,
that tree doesn't look right.
Oh, no.
It's just a regular tree.
Sorry.
That's like how it's gonna beat up a tree.
I can't believe that was insta-kill.
That's so bullshit.
That was actually bullshit.
Win.
Fuck this.
I learned my lesson.
I fucking learned my lesson.
Fuck you and your stupid stupid bombs.
Now I know.
Now I fucking know.
You don't got me this time.
You don't got me this time, bitch.
Yeah.
That's fine.
We know now.
We know now, chat.
You don't got me this time.
That's fucking right.
You know what?
I don't even need that.
I did it just cause.
And now, big monkey.
That's right.
I swear to god, if you guys die again, I swear to god, guys.
Guys.
You guys can't die again, guys.
Another big monkey.
All the monkeys.
Yeah.
Let all the monkeys roam.
Nice.
I got my cold iron leaves.
Alright.
Okay.
Nice.
Monkey two together.
Strong.
Alright.
How many more optional bosses do we have left, chat?
How many more?
The homies.
Me and the homies.
We love cold iron leaves.
Two more?
What are the other two?
We already got the frog.
What's the other one that we don't need?
Oh, I like this music though.
This music is fucking jamming.
Ooh.
My PNG cloud.
Big rock?
There's big rock?
Really big rock?
How many rocks are there?
Oh, no.
We killed the clapping rock baby.
Don't worry.
That was like one of the first optional bosses we got.
I made sure.
He looked at me weird.
Okay.
We got the clapping rock.
We got the hippo.
We got the lizard.
And we got the sleeping rock.
Those are all the optional bosses, right?
I'm gonna kill a mountain?
Okay.
How do we...
How do we get the missing...
How do we get the missing item again?
We travel.
Wait.
Dragon?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
The lizard.
The big lizard.
Chapter 3.
Who the fuck is this guy?
New West?
Okay.
Oh, it's this?
New West.
Okay.
Mindfulness Cliff Keeper Shrine.
Which one is that?
Oh, here.
That's chapter 2.
Sorry I can't count.
Creeper, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The monkey.
Go forth and drop off the wooden bridge.
Okay.
That should be the last one.
Oh, I see it!
I see the instructions.
Okay.
So we drop off here.
And then we grab this.
Cause that's a heal.
That's some money.
Even though we don't need it.
We don't need it, but like...
I still want it.
And then we go up.
Oh, there it is!
Oh my god.
How weak are they now?
Wait.
They're not weak.
Wait, what?
Oh wait, no.
They are.
They literally took like...
They literally took like one combo.
Now follow the path.
Fuck you!
I'm angry.
So I take my anger out of you guys.
That's right.
Oh shit!
That doesn't stop me.
Two people to be angry at.
What a bargain.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Wait.
Which path?
Oh, there's a path here.
A cycle.
Never break the cycle.
Just gonna get rid of them for now.
Oh my god.
Stop blocking the pathway!
This is why I killed you!
Yeah, they're very annoying.
You know what?
It was overkill, but like...
Like...
It might be overkill, but like...
Look, he was in the way!
It was self-defense!
He shot first.
You can tell he shot first.
Is this the item?
No, that's just a gourd.
Why don't you try... Wait.
Hello?
A rat?
I thought I killed all the rats!
What are you doing here?
Oh shit, this is it!
Yeah, self doesn't exist for you.
Oh, there you go.
The thought.
Oh, and then we get back to the shrine.
Nice.
The last survivor!
How did you live?
You were all supposed to die.
Wait, do I have five?
I have four, I think.
Let me go check.
One, two, three, four.
Okay.
Does this count?
No.
No, we're missing one more.
Oh, it's from chapter six?
Oh, I only need four.
Okay.
Alright.
Um...
Okay, we just gotta figure out how to get to...
Alright.
If you fly backwards to the mountain behind it, you'll find a free armor set by the tree.
Okay, but first I want to beat up the... I want to beat up the...
I want to beat up the giant mountain.
I will be the only rock remaining.
The only sentient rock.
Alright.
What looks like a giant mount... Oh, there he is!
I see him.
Is that him?
No, that's just a regular mountain.
I thought that was him.
No, that is him.
Wait, that is him.
This is where I beat up the rock baby.
He was sitting there looking at me from here.
Yeah.
I remember.
He literally sat there and looked at me.
This is where he sat.
Right here.
Here?
Where?
Oh, there.
I'm so lost.
It's too open.
I can't figure out my direction.
Okay, thank god I have the cloud.
I'm so lost.
Here we go.
I was like, is it... Oh, there.
There it is.
Holy fuck!
Okay.
Alright, let's do this.
I shall be the only sentient rock in this world.
Oh!
What the fuck that?
Okay, I...
Guys, I...
I think I might...
Guys...
Okay.
Guys, I think I was a little...
Whoa.
Guys, I think maybe I was just a little too overzealous.
I think...
Guys, when you said...
Guys, when you said he's a giant fucking rock mountain, I...
You know, I thought it was a tiny mountain.
This is not a tiny mountain.
Guys, This is absolutely... this is not a tiny mountain, the guy.
This is... this is a very big mountain.
Guys, my minions are just as confused as to where to go.
They... they don't know where to go.
Like, why did I summon them?
We're all so confused.
We're all... we're actually so...
Like, we're... we're doing smack.
We're all... where are they going?
Where... where are they going?
Okay, now I know to not summon anything.
Okay, do not summon the... do not summon the little rock baby.
Do not... do not summon them.
That was a waste of time and magic.
Monkey see monkey lies.
They were so lost.
That was the worst part.
But...
Crushed!
Okay, we got... we don't have the shrine.
Like, I got splashed.
Like, I thought...
You know, we all saw how big the other rock babies... all the rock people were.
I thought it'd be different.
Like, I thought it would...
Okay, clearly...
Okay, wait, I got an idea.
I don't think the fan will be useful here because I don't think I'm gonna...
I don't think...
I don't think the fan's gonna be useful.
Okay.
A blue rock?
There's a blue rock?
Okay, this is where I killed the child.
The rock child.
This is where...
He literally laughed at me, guys.
I have to teach him my lesson.
Okay.
And then we go straight.
Where's the shrine though?
You all saw him clapping.
He was clapping and laughing.
What was he laughing about then, huh?
Chat?
What was he laughing about if it wasn't at me?
Explain that.
Not at you.
Then who was it?
He was really brave.
Where's the shrine?
He was laughing.
The cricket was dead and yet he was still laughing.
Where's the shrine?
No.
No!
This is not fair!
I...
Um.
What?!
What the fuck happened!
I already...
What the fuck!
What happened to me?
What...
I already lost two...
Guys, this is bullshit.
I was trying to find the shrine.
I'm sorry guys.
I'm trying to find the fucking stride.
This is actually bullshit.
I'm lagging, dude.
Nothing is going right for Doki.
Oh my god, he's so far.
Wow!
When is he gonna show his hand?
I wanna fucking play.
I wanna play.
When is the hand gonna get closer?
Whoa!
Please get closer.
Please!
Is that?
This is it.
This is not it.
You can't be in there.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't.
Baby, please.
This is fine.
Okay, I get it.
I get it now, guys.
I figured it out.
Guys, I figured it out, guys.
Oh my god!
I figured it out!
This is so easy!
Holy shit!
And then I run.
He can't reach me now, bitch.
That's fucking right.
I know where your edge is.
That's right.
You know what?
Oh.
I thought it would...
I thought...
I thought when I was so...
It would...
It would go over there, but I guess not.
I thought he would...
I thought the thing would head over, but...
But...
I might have wasted that.
Nito is also lost.
Nito doesn't know where to go.
Okay, goodbye, Nito.
I thought...
I thought the Nito would go after I did that.
But he was like...
No, that's the wrong...
Wrong...
Wrong story.
I thought...
I thought my Nito would just fucking run over there.
Alright.
Double smash!
Just double smash!
Oh, double smash.
He's double smashing.
He heard me.
He actually heard me.
I'm heading over.
I'm almost there.
I'm so close.
Here we go.
We did it.
We made it.
This is gonna take forever.
But, like, we're here.
Oh, the metal!
Oh my god.
We could've smashed the blue parts of his head.
Guys, now we know.
Now, fuck.
Okay, now we know, guys.
Now we know.
I know you guys all yelled at me about the blue part.
But I just... I saw arms.
What is he gonna do?
Hello?
Yeah, that's right.
What you gonna do?
You just gonna watch?
Okay.
Haha, that's right.
You can't...
You can't reach me.
That's fucking right.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, what you gonna do?
That's right.
Get out of your fucking hole and fight me!
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I didn't wanna get, like, you know, crushed again.
And what you gonna do, huh?
That's right.
You have no range, you bitch.
No range, ass.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Okay, I forgot.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
The blue crystals.
The blue hands.
There we go.
Guys, we learned!
We learned about the blue!
Oh, I used the wrong stance.
Whoops.
Hahaha.
Big baby!
No!
You son of...
Oh, no.
No!
Sorry, I freaked out.
I freaked out.
Wait, is he dead?
Oh, he's dead.
Nice.
Okay.
That's...
He just dies?
Okay.
Alright.
I mean, okay.
Nice.
It's my mountain now.
I will be the last remaining rock child.
Oh, it was a bamboo!
I mean, bamboo.
I mean...
Yeah.
Bamboo!
It was a bamboo.
Sorry.
What is she doing?
Oh my gosh, she's grabbing the eye!
Oh!
What the fuck?
She's a murderer.
What is she doing?
What the fuck is she doing?
Oh, for me?
Nice.
Yeah, but my...
I had intentions.
My...
My murder was fueled by...
was fueled by my goal of being the only...
the only sentient rock.
That's different.
Like, I have intentions for my murder.
Yeah, exactly.
There can only be one sentient rock.
I did it.
I got the consciousness.
Who is he?
Oh, the mandrill's chief.
Oh, wait!
She knows me!
I just went back and became a stone.
Yeah, that sounds like me.
Oh!
She wanted to cure me!
And then I'm just like, you did all that work, and I'm alive.
She did all that, but I was alive in the end.
Yeah, she's my mom!
Alright.
The dog will turn them into buffs.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Let me go back to the... I like how I got this and it didn't matter.
Oh, nice.
We did it.
Yay!
Okay, instant transmission.
Alright, we gotta go back to do final upgrades.
Alright, let's max out our armor, too.
Since we're at the final boss, it's time.
I'm sorry, I know I look so fucking cool.
God, now I have to relive the past.
I'm a... I'm my own monkey!
I'm my own monkey, though.
I looked so cool before it.
Oh, I can't max it?
Oh my god, I ordered all this for no reason?
Don't say that.
No.
No, no.
Wukong 2, the DLC.
The DLC, guys.
You mean I could've upgraded the gold armor?
And took fire early on and never had to...
Oh, that's awkward.
That's so awkward.
That's so fucked.
That's actually...
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm so sad now.
I'm so sad.
Yeah, but I'll just... Oh, hello.
Alright, hello.
Magic.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, goodbye.
Let's see.
Well, where am I going?
Oh, yeah, here.
I have it.
Well, where am I going?
The us.
Woah!
What does it do?
Made to increase multiple attributes?
Or just eat- Oh!
Oh, now I have everything!
Okay.
Alright, we have 17!
Okay, we'll do one of everything.
Do we need stamina recovery rate chat or are we good?
Should we?
HP, I'll just do HP.
I'll do one of everything.
Okay, I'll do one of everything then.
Yeah, I can afford it.
Okay, max out health and mana?
I mean, how much do I need?
It's the final boss time.
5, 3, 2, 1.
Is it worth it to max it out?
Oh.
Oh, no.
No.
Okay, I'll do two.
I'll do two for health and two for mana.
You need to max it out?
Okay.
Whoa, okay.
Okay, I guess...
I guess I'll max it out.
And I still have...
I don't think I can max this out.
I'll do...
Make it so that they're the same.
Okay.
Okay, mana.
Okay, and then we'll put the rest on HP.
I guess we'll put the rest on HP then.
Right?
Or should we put some on defense and stamina?
Is it worth it?
I don't know.
I don't know if I should put some in...
Maybe I'll do one defense.
Oh, but then I can't max out HP.
Defense?
Okay, I'll do...
I'll do three on defense.
And then...
Oh, no need for defense?
Okay, then I'll put it all on HP.
All right, all in.
All in!
You have no choice but to face the punishment.
All right, we're all in.
Okay, here we go.
Now we're poor.
Take the medicine!
I can't believe I didn't upgrade my armor.
I'm so sad.
I didn't...
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I didn't...
I could've upgraded my Cold Armor.
Okay, let's see.
Okay, we traveled.
I don't remember where the water... Oh wait, I've lost two of my left.
I remember now.
It's where I killed the baby.
This is like where I remember things.
Where did I kill the rock baby?
It's like I'm figuring out the direction.
I find where I killed the rock baby and then I know where I am.
I don't know why, but that's where I killed him.
Right over there, you see that?
That's where I killed him.
He was looking at me right there.
Okay, let's go here.
Oh, it glitched out again.
Okay.
Um...
Do I have it?
I'm wearing everything, right?
Yeah.
Why is it not five?
What do you mean five?
This is four!
Oh, is it my staff?
How is it five?
Oh, it's the last... Do I... I can't use Erdon's staff?
No!
Can I not use it?
Oh, I'm about to get it.
Yeah, but like, I'm not gonna change into that armor though.
Like, is it worth getting the armor?
Okay.
Absolutely okay.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Back to my house.
Alright.
Where is it?
Knock knock!
Wait, why am I knocking?
This is where I live.
Home sweet home!
Wait, who light the fire here?
Wait a minute.
Who fucking...
Who fucking broke into my home?
Somebody light the fire here and it wasn't me because I still don't have my memory yet.
Who broke into my home?
Oh, I can use it.
No, not to use my stupid legs.
No, not my legs.
Not to walk like a fucking regular monkey.
Oh, that's my staff!
I made it big!
Oh, that's cool.
That's my staff right there.
Is he gonna say anything?
I have to...
Oh, that's my fucking tiger pelt shit.
That I sometimes have.
Bro, what the fuck?
Disrespectful.
Where did you come from?
I am a monkey from the Great Sheng.
I am just a normal monkey.
Your face is so ugly.
You look like a pile of thunder.
This is a monster that doesn't come out.
Oh, he's reliving memories.
This is like GTA RP, but like Wukong's own server.
Yeah, he's reliving the memories he had with Wukong.
I haven't been here in a long time.
I don't think it's still the same.
Back in the day, he was sitting on this chair.
And he was pressing me against his head.
What happened to him?
Look, there was a lot of spoilage.
Look, guys.
There was a lot of things going on.
In the background.
There was a lot of physics.
Oh.
Put it in my ear.
Wait.
It's supposed to go in my ear.
Oh, you don't know?
He hides the staff in his ear.
I don't know why.
But like...
I mean like...
He could literally just hold it.
But like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
For those who don't know.
In the story, he puts this in his ear.
So like, people will think he's not armed.
And then he'll be like, Oh, you think I'm not armed?
And then he takes it out of his ear.
He just likes it like that.
Yeah.
Wait, it was the back of his ear?
I always thought it was in his ear.
Because it always seems like it goes in his ear every time.
Yeah, I thought it was inside.
Yeah, I'm correct!
I knew I was correct!
I was like, no, it clearly was inside his ear.
Oh, shit.
I'm worthy.
I knew it.
I was like, there's no way.
I'm pretty sure it's in his ear.
But yeah, I don't know why he did.
I don't know.
I guess it's like...
People don't know he's armed.
But then, like, when you see Wukong...
When you see Xu Menghong...
And he's wearing the band on his head.
Like, you know he's fucking armed.
He's literally a fucking monkey with armor.
It's just very heavy.
I mean, he could just...
Let's go!
We got it!
We got his staff!
Try hard...
Try and hold for... Okay, let's see.
Whoa!
Look at my arm!
Oh wait, you guys can't see it.
Alright.
Oh, that looks strong.
Wait, that shit looks strong.
I'm finally him, guys.
I'm him.
Where do I go?
Let's go.
This way?
Oh, this way.
Where's the hole?
Guys, is the hole right in the giant hole in front of us?
I'm him now.
Oh my god, where could it be?
It could never...
Oh my god, could it be the giant hole that's right in front of us?
Guys, no way.
Let's go.
Okay.
Oh, I just did.
No, I saw it.
It was fucking insane.
That looked like a lot of damage.
Oh, I can craft?
This is the one I have.
What can I craft?
This one?
The 30?
Like, I'm just like wondering, was it trying to make me craft the one that says 30?
Like, Jesus.
Oh, that wasn't four?
Oh, I don't have focus point four.
Wait, can I go beyond four?
What the fuck happened?
No, I'm just vibrating.
I only had three.
Woo!
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
I'm going to try this.
Please.
Okay.
I can't do the thing.
Yeah.
I don't have the fourth focus point.
No, I have enough.
I hoarded it just for that.
Okay.
I don't have 20, guys.
All right.
Number five.
What's that?
Okay.
That's awkward.
Wait.
I don't need my stances then, right?
Technically, I don't need my stances, right?
I do?
Where do I put it on?
Okay.
I guess I'll put...
Health stats.
I'll take...
Which one do I take it off?
Okay.
I'll take that.
Remove mana.
Okay.
I'll do...
I need to go to the shrine.
Give me a sec.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'll be right back, Tupac.
I'll be right back.
Let's see.
He'll be fine, right?
Oh, should I use spellbinding?
Is that a thing?
For this?
Okay.
I mean, we don't need spin.
We don't need spin.
We don't need a spin, guys.
Okay, we should have it now.
There we go.
Spell is binary strong?
Alright, it's time.
It's time then.
It's time.
Okay.
Okay, let's grab...
Wait, why did you guys make me increase mana?
What the fuck?
Guys, why did you make me waste it on the mana?
Okay.
Oh, mana makes it stronger.
More mana, more damage.
Okay.
Thank god.
I was gonna be very mad.
I was gonna be like, what the fuck?
What was the point?
Okay, there we go.
We got spellbinder.
And I guess we'll get rid of monkeys too.
We'll get rid of monkeys.
Okay, we're gonna do this.
And then we'll...
Sprint.
Defense.
There we go.
We still have...
two more.
There we go.
Oh, you're right.
Why am I not maxing out my mana?
There we go.
I think we're good.
We're okay.
Is he still fighting?
I was gonna say, is he still fighting?
Did I left?
Alright, let's see.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Don't worry.
I can move while doing this.
Okay, nice.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna go ahead.
Look, it was really nice of him to let me like...
Let me...
Let me move out.
That was really nice of him.
Not gonna lie.
I really appreciate it, guys.
That really means a lot.
That you guys let me just, you know, walk over.
I forgot to set the spell on there.
Oh my god.
Okay, give me a sec.
Sorry, Chupacay.
Sorry for the detour.
Sorry.
Okay, let's see.
Let's set spells.
Spellbinder.
There we go.
Alright, here we go.
We got it.
We're fine.
What do I need?
Up big baby.
Yeah, big baby has been there from the beginning.
I never changed big baby.
Alright, up we go.
Up we fucking go.
Okay, whatever.
You guys see the tiny, the very, very tiny...
Okay, alright.
If I heal, there we go.
The very, the very fucking tiny little speck.
That's actually bullshit.
Holy shit.
The very, very tiny little speck.
Oh my god.
That's actually bullshit.
Alright.
Don't worry, we're okay.
It's cause I maxed out my mana.
It's from the mana max.
Oh my god.
I...
Oh god, Chewbacca.
Nice.
They're still alive, but like, you know, it's a...
It looked cool though.
Bro, it looked so cool.
It might have done like nothing, but it looked so cool, bro.
It's alright.
It's okay, bro.
As long as it looked cool.
As long as it looked so fucking cool.
It's okay.
I have Spellbinder on chat.
He didn't max out his mana.
You could have run... I thought I was supposed to fight them.
Am I not?
No.
No rest.
Just fight.
Why rest when I can fight?
Free XP.
Yeah, it's cooler if I fight them.
Alright.
Are they all dead?
Yeah, I want the XP.
No rest, only fight.
I thought he was gonna kill them, you know, when he ran at them, but that's alright.
You know what?
Maybe you're right.
Maybe if I just run.
Like, what are they gonna do?
Oh, they're so slow.
Wait, they're so... look at these guys.
And they're from the Celestial Core?
My god.
Bro, what the fuck?
You guys are from the Celestial Core?
Like...
Look at these guys.
Look at them.
They can't even run up properly.
Oh, he's coming for me.
He's coming for me.
Okay.
We're fine.
Oh, we made it.
This looks safe.
Wait, which way do I go?
Oh, this way.
This looks so safe.
Are they still...
Okay, they're just gone.
Wait, my stamina is not going down.
Is it because of this level?
I just realized that.
Oh, through the...
through the crevices.
That's because I'm cool.
Hello?
It's so calm now.
Oh.
A loading screen crevice.
I'm him.
That's me.
That's right.
Oh.
Oh, I thought we were still loading.
I thought...
I thought something was going to happen.
I don't know.
I thought something was going to happen there.
Can we get the graphics back?
Okay, do you think it'll be okay?
Do you think it'll be...
Alright.
We'll see when we make it.
Guys, there's a lot of grass everywhere.
Guys, I don't know about it.
Not now.
Not now yet.
There's a lot of stuff going around us.
Look at the trees.
Look at all these leaves over here.
A lot of vegetation, exactly.
There's a lot of vegetation right now.
Alright.
Up we go.
Oh, that's me!
That's me!
That's my egg!
My monkey egg!
Wake up!
My rock egg!
That's me!
Look at me!
I'm like a little fetus.
Where am I?
Wait a minute.
Obsession.
A remnant worldly ties and transforms the unfinished aspirations into spaces both tangible and ethereal.
Real and illusionary.
Through certain objects, one can navigate these spaces.
It all comes back to rock.
It's where I was born!
Wait, what are you doing in my fucking egg fetus?
In my yolk!
What is he doing in my yolk?
Hm.
I'm here.
Get on the boat.
I say, old man.
If you get on this boat, you won't be able to turn back, right?
There's no such thing as a boat in this world.
If you don't get on my boat, do you think you'll be able to turn back?
Oh, that's deep.
That's very deep.
Back into the rock.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys,
you can tell...
You can tell the graphics quality is hitting that old monkey hard right now.
You can tell it's hitting him really hard.
That's me!
That's me.
Wait, why am I naked?
Kings don't get... no, non-kings don't get clothes.
They were killing the other monkeys!
Yeah, because they discriminated me!
What the fuck?
What?
You're either king and clothed or not and naked.
What the fuck?
You're a monkey too!
You should be fighting for my monkey rights!
You wanna be treated like trash?
He just said we're like rats!
Can't believe he compared us to rats!
This part is a lot of narration.
Are you only reading the syllabus or do you understand them?
I can understand a bit of it, but then they get like super poetic or like super deep.
Like the way some of the dialogue is like really complicated that I don't know the words of.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
You're welcome!
Like when they get like... There's like some old...
Some like... like what's the word?
Like there's some words I don't know.
Yeah that's the double meanings and metaphors.
Yeah.
Why's the monkey so bright?
Um...
Why am I lagging?
My good friend.
My good friend?
Who?
Yeah, but most of them are dead.
Why is that?
Yeah, same.
Most of my friends are fucking dead.
Yeah, where are they?
Who killed them?
I wonder who fucking killed them.
Why the fuck is that tree monkey?
Are we here?
Are we there yet?
What the fuck?
What is this paradox?
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, that's me.
You're mine.
Yeah.
That's me.
That has to be me, right?
I'm the mine.
It's me, isn't it?
It's not me.
It's him.
Bro, just because he's old doesn't mean he's wise.
I'm literally...
I told you, I'm him.
I like how he thought it was the older monkey just because he's old.
Bro, I'm right here.
Like, I literally look like him.
Like, I'm just like...
I literally look like him and he was like, Oh, it's the old monkey.
Like, that's so fucked.
Yeah, but I'm here.
you fucked.
He Club.
he Club.
he club.
He was fucked.
he Emil waves He was fucked.
gor richie How beautiful.
He's bright.
I was too young for that.
I mean, he's like 8 times immortal.
So I'm like basically the reincarnation of him.
I never even had a name!
Bro, even though I'm like his reincarnation...
He could at least give me a name.
I'm just a monkey.
I didn't even look like him!
He's dead!
Bro, okay, the side play is like, he's long gone.
He was like, he's fucking dead!
Fuck, I like that so fucked up!
Bro!
Like, the whole monkey was like, he's fucking dead!
I like how the subtitle was like, bro, he's god.
What he actually said was so much more mean.
It was so mean.
You gotta let go.
He's dead.
Bro, he's hella dead.
Yeah, he's dead.
Wait, what is he then, if I'm the mind, is that the body?
Yeah, that's the body, it got merged with him.
Why the fuck we needed a boat!
Hahaha!
We couldn't walk blocked.
Yeah, it's another test.
Another test?
Underwater was deeply...
We put a barrier?
I'm literally him!
The final test.
This is my destiny.
Oh god, okay.
That's fine.
I forgot to use my abilities.
Okay, this is not fine.
Guys, I already forgot to use my abilities.
I can't believe I already forgot to use my abilities.
Whoops.
That's awkward.
I forgot they existed.
I forgot my abilities.
I forgot my...
What the fuck?
Okay.
It's fine.
What is he doing?
Okay, I need to jump more.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, that's not fine.
I don't know his stuff.
Oh, I don't know what...
Please.
I don't know what he's doing sometimes.
Oh, fuck.
No!
What?
What is that?
Okay, I tried to jump, guys.
But it didn't work.
No, it did not work.
Oh, my God.
I swear to God, guys.
I tried to jump.
You are him.
Just win.
Wait, now he's...
Now he's rock monkey?
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I don't reset my thing.
That's very good to know.
Okay, now that...
All right.
Oh, my God.
I didn't get the timing for that.
No!
Okay.
All right.
It's fine.
Okay, that's good.
I got the timing for that.
Even...
No!
Oh, he's picking up a rock!
Every time.
Come on.
Use my giant ability!
There's two!
That's not fair!
That's so not fair, bro.
No!
Bro!
Oh, no!
Damn!
Fuck!
Okay.
Oh, I need to figure out how to do the jumps.
No first try, guys.
Two is a bit too much.
Two is a bit...
Okay.
Oh, now we have the shrine.
All right.
Two...
Monkey to get a shrine.
Where did they go?
Wait, they left!
Wait!
They left!
That's right!
Monkey versus monkey!
Monkey versus monkey time!
If you...
Oh, now it's my turn!
You have two monkeys!
That's right!
It's my turn!
It's fucking my turn!
That's right!
My turn!
You have two monkeys!
I'm just gonna wait for my other monkey to hit him more.
Might as well.
Oh, no.
Fuck it.
I'm just gonna beat him up.
Baby!
Fed!
Nice.
And now...
Now I have this.
That's right.
I got the pattern!
I got the pattern going in!
Okay, now I can't...
I don't have anything else now.
I don't have it.
I got first phase is easy.
I don't know how many phases this monkey has.
But I assume it's a lot.
Woo!
No, I mistimed that.
No, I mistimed that!
Oh, god.
Okay.
This phase is weird.
It's very weird, guys.
It's so weird.
I don't know.
Oh, god.
I'm just gonna let him do that thing.
Nice.
Okay.
That's fine.
No!
It's not fine!
Guys, it was not fine.
JK.
What?
That was behind you!
He was literally behind you!
That's fucked.
Oh, no!
He did rock parry!
How did you do...
No!
He grabbed me!
Teleporting rock!
Please!
I'm just trying to...
What?
No!
Oh, no!
I didn't mean to do that!
Oh, whatever.
It's fine.
We're here anyway.
We might as well be here.
Oh, god.
No!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
That's fine.
I'm just gonna...
Oh, it's gonna...
What?
Where did he go?
I hate this.
I hate two.
Two is fucking me up, guys.
Two is way too many.
No.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's not fine.
Guys, it's not fine.
It's actually not fine, guys.
Oh, thank god.
It's one.
One monkey now.
Oh, thank god.
It's one monkey now.
That's not fair!
That's actually...
No!
You cheater!
What?
How did he know?
Oh, fucking hell.
Why can't I do that?
If I'm him, I should be able to do all of that.
Like, not gonna lie.
All I'm saying is that if I'm supposed to be him, All I'm saying is that if I'm supposed to be him, I should be allowed to do...
Oh, my god.
I should be allowed to do all of this.
You're not him.
But...
He literally said I am!
Are you trying to tell me the old man was lying?
There's no way he's old.
He can't lie to me.
He's supposed to be wise.
Jeez.
Oh, I hate this guy so much.
I hate him.
Oh, god.
Okay, I dodged it.
Oh, I didn't dodge that, though.
I...
Oh,
I accidentally dragged two.
No.
Are you serious?
Oh, he missed.
He grabs twice!
The Celestial Court hates you!
I hate me too!
No wonder...
I don't know why.
Now I know.
Please!
Oh!
Phase three.
Phase fucking three.
Because he is the grappler.
Did I do it?
My stick!
That's right.
Nice!
I'm him.
You might have more experience.
But I'm basically you.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I didn't even have to take off my hair.
That's right.
I don't even need to pluck my hair now.
Oh!
Oh, shit!
That's right.
I'm you.
I'm the better version of you.
I'm iPhone 15.
And you're iPhone 14.
What number iPhone we are on now?
I come in pink now.
We're on 16.
Sorry.
Whoa!
Wait!
You're me!
That's iPhone 16.
Oh, no!
The iPhone 16 just came out!
No!
That's iPhone 16!
I'm 16!
Nice!
Oh,
no!
My own moveset!
You know I have not.
You know I have not mastered my own movesets, guys.
Guys, no!
He is iPhone 16!
He's spinning!
Holy shit!
He actually knows how to spin!
He dodged too!
Oh, my God!
He's thrusting!
He has so many combos!
I didn't know they existed until now!
So many!
I haven't seen some of these combos before!
Not gonna lie!
Some of these combos, I didn't even know they existed!
Oh, my God!
Oh, shit!
Okay, I dodged it.
Just in time.
Oh!
I'm gonna full heal, just in case.
Like, I don't trust myself.
Not gonna lie.
What the fuck?!
That's actually cheating!
Holy shit!
Did he actually cheat with that?
Oh, my God!
That's crazy!
Full healing.
Just in case.
I don't trust myself.
Guys, you don't understand.
He is iPhone syrup.
Wait, Phase 4?!
I fucking full...
I deceased!
I crashed!
I actually crashed!
I saw Phase 4, and I was gone.
I thought I was fucking gone.
I thought I was supposed to be the soul.
Let's give me a sec guys.
Oh please don't fucking fight yet.
I'm trying to get back in.
Oh no.
I'm back in.
I think I should be back in.
Wait why am I not out there yet?
Wait what?
He's at 17 left.
What the fuck?
Wait he's being cocky.
Did he get back his memories too?
Like did you absorb me?
I was supposed to absorb you.
That's not how it's supposed to go.
I said I was supposed to absorb you.
No that's right.
You thought you might know how to parry.
Oh shit.
Okay and that too.
Wait I can't do the other stances anymore.
He took it away from me.
Oh shit ring of fire.
I've never seen that before.
Guys.
He's using ring of fire.
We've never seen.
No we cannot let him pluck.
We cannot let him pluck guys.
Does that move exist?
What are these moves that he's doing?
Does that thing exist?
Okay nice.
No!
How did you?
Okay.
That's actually bullshit.
Not gonna lie.
Oh my god.
Oh I'm dead.
I don't have guys.
Oh goodbye.
What if I just.
Goodbye everybody.
Phase 4.
He stole my focus.
Oh my god.
No Gordon.
A dream.
Wait.
Oh my god I have a checkpoint.
Oh thank god.
That means I can do it.
I can do my thing again.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Now I'm mountain monkey.
That's fucking right.
Oh shit.
You do so much.
What the fuck.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's fine.
I guess.
Okay.
Did I.
I did not hit.
But that's.
Okay.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
Alright.
Bro.
Wait.
Oh thank god.
Okay.
I got it.
Thank god.
Oh wait.
One.
Here we go.
We have this.
Thank god.
I can do this now.
Oh shit.
Ring of fire.
That's illegal.
I've never used ring of fire.
You're supposed to be also me.
But I don't use ring of fire.
Oh nice.
Alright.
How are you me if you use moves I don't use.
That doesn't make sense.
It's time to update the iOS.
All I'm saying is that.
How is he me if he uses moves that I never use.
Oh not the ring of fire.
Bro.
He went out the ring of fire.
I thought that doesn't exist.
How did you get out of it?
Oh okay.
Okay.
I just need to be sure.
Nice.
Oh shit.
Alright.
I'm backing out so I can heal.
Not because I'm scared of you.
It's not fair.
You like took my all my stance stuff too.
I.
Okay.
That's.
That's fucked.
What he just did.
Was actually so toxic.
Not gonna lie.
That was so toxic.
He actually was the most toxic piece of shit.
What the fuck.
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
I don't need it.
I don't need it at all.
I don't.
I don't need you.
Oh.
That's fine.
That's also fine.
Oh my god.
I forgot other stances.
Guys.
It's been so long.
I forgot other stances existed.
Guys.
I actually forgot other stances existed.
I've been using.
Nons.
God.
You bitch.
I was trying to do that.
You actual bitch.
No.
I'll bonk you first.
Okay.
God damn it.
No.
I don't know your pattern.
You're mean.
But you use moves I never use.
Like.
How is this fairway.
I never use any moves.
I don't even know how many of these.
Here we go.
Oh god.
Not the ring of fire.
What.
He can fight on the cloud.
That's actually fucked.
He can fight on the cloud too.
Like.
He has everything I've ever wanted in this game.
I bet I can't even do that in a new game.
Please.
God damn it.
Nons that's the worst part.
That's the worst part.
No.
I actually first killed.
But he wouldn't let me.
I even scrolled to it.
I even scrolled to it too.
I can't believe it.
I scrolled to this and it didn't register.
Nons.
Oh my god, that's so messed up.
I'm just gonna use baby first just because he's sitting down.
Because he's sitting down, I'll use it first.
Jesus.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I need my heals back.
Get over here.
Get over here, me.
That's where I'll lock you in this corner.
When I- okay, when I get this hit on.
Okay.
I'll still punch you until you're dead!
Oh, come on!
Get over here!
Oh, you're gonna use ring of fire?
You think I care about ring of fire?
I'm fucking walking into the ring of fire.
I'm gonna keep walking into the ring of fire.
That's fucking right.
Okay, and now I'll use this- NO, I DIDN'T!
I MADE THE FAN!
Fuck, okay, nevermind.
Alright, we're gonna- Okay, this is bad.
I was supposed to use the fan.
This is bad.
This is a little bad.
I fucked up already.
I was supposed to use- It's okay.
It's okay.
Sometimes, we're here to make it a little bit harder for ourselves, because we like- We like it.
We like- We like the challenge.
We really like the challenge.
That's just it.
It's fun.
It's so fun.
Okay.
My turn.
BAM!
Sounds like... oh.
We're just challenge enjoyers.
Oh my god.
This... this move is so bullshit.
Okay.
I need to like focus on dodging his attacks.
Nice.
Okay.
I figured out the pattern, I think.
Oh.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
This is the first time I hit the rock!
Bro, what the fuck?
You're just standing there.
What?
Bro!
Oh, thank you.
Thank you for the stick.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
Thank you for the stick, sir.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I dodged in time.
My turn.
He can do that?
Why can't I do that?
He can just grab my stick?
He can freeze me too?
Guys, this is not fair.
What?
My hands are off the keyboard.
This is...
When did he start doing all of these moves?
When?
When did he learn...
Whoa!
When?
When did he learn how to do all these moves?
I don't understand!
I...
Why did he do these before?
Why did he...
Why did he do any of these moves?
I don't understand.
There's...
There's so many new moves that I've never seen before.
There's so many...
Oh, he's just gonna do all these moves.
SHIT!
EVERYTHING IS NEW!
OH MY GOD!
Goodbye, cruel world.
Goodbye.
I'm just gonna... just get this over with.
Like,
he can fucking grab the stick?!
What do you... What do you mean he can just grab the stick?!
What do you mean?!
What do you mean he can just grab it?!
I didn't know he could do that!
Oh, someone should just do this.
Oh my god, you're right.
This is smart.
And then I could just do that.
Oh shit, you're right!
Now it's big baby time.
Yeah, that's right.
And now it's fan time.
Okay, now it's fan time.
What are you gonna do?
Oh, okay.
Thank god.
Okay, I was gonna say...
I don't need monkey.
I don't need...
I don't need to use my fucking...
Uh, what's it called?
I have this now.
Oh god.
Nice, I dodged it.
Okay, he dodged it too, but that...
Oh, he dodged everything.
That's okay.
Stuff happens.
That's fine.
Oh, that's fine.
That is not fine, but that's okay.
I dodged that.
That is not fine, but it's okay.
All right.
Okay, we figured this out.
Oh my god.
I keep fucking that up.
I keep forgetting he can do that and I...
Because he took me in.
He absorbed me and I keep forgetting he can actually do that now.
Oh my god, did you see that?
I dodged it!
Okay, that was cool.
You have to admit, that was actually cool.
Okay.
That's Ricky, right?
Oh, he didn't grab it this time.
Thank god.
Oh no, not the ring of fire.
No, not that too!
Okay, I dodged it.
Okay.
Full focus.
Okay, full focus.
You gotta focus more.
No, don't grab this.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I'm always so scared he's gonna grab.
Dodged it.
That's good.
Okay, I grabbed, dodged it too.
I think.
I don't think I grabbed.
Dodged it, guys.
Wait, what did he do?
I just...
Okay.
Oh, he did that.
I was like, what was that?
Fine!
Ah!
Oh noo.
My poor body!
He fucking confused it!
Oh, thank god.
Every day I'm worried that he's gonna grab it Ever since he did that one move.
I'm so paranoid that he's just gonna grab my stick now So...
Oh, God.
Oh, thank God.
Please don't grab.
Thank God.
Okay.
Guys, you don't understand.
As long as he doesn't grab it, I'm okay.
Okay, but what if I do this?
Oh.
Oh, no.
No!
I missed!
Come on, reload.
Reload.
Okay.
Come on.
Okay, thank God.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Last... No!
Okay.
Hail Mary.
This is my Hail Mary attempt.
Oh, God.
No!
Okay.
Oh, God.
Are you serious?
Oh, he fucking... Okay, I don't know where that was supposed to go, but that's fine.
Guys, I don't think this is the run.
No!
Wait, is there another phase?
Please.
There's no way.
The name didn't show up.
This is why I don't change my phone.
iPhone 15.
Oh, my God.
I don't need the upgrade to iPhone 16.
Let's go.
I don't need that pink iPhone.
Oh, it's coming back.
My memory's...
Oh... Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you. No, the one who became a Buddha is not him at all.
The real him has long died on the path of enlightenment.
And some people say that I am him.
I am him.
So he is...
He is...
The...
The binds.
Wait, what?
The circlet, yeah.
You are iPhone.
Wait, no, get that shit away from me.
What the fuck?
Get away!
This is when I died.
Oh, this is when I became... when I finished my journey.
No, I killed my own car.
Yeah.
This is... that was the ending.
This is us heading to the journey.
I'm happy that we never saw that other guy in the group.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, this is in reverse.
This is the whole story in reverse, is it?
Yeah, I never saw Sandy.
I never saw him.
To be fair, he...
I personally think like...
I don't think he's anyone's favorite character.
But like, unless, you know, sorry.
I always forget him.
I know what he looks like, but I always forget his name.
He's just there.
Okay, everyone.
Yeah, because nobody really...
...hears about him.
Everyone always talks about Chupacca, Shrimpong, and Sifu.
But no one talks about the other guy.
Oh, this is when I was like mad about the thing.
I care.
He was... yeah, he was there to carry the bags.
Poor Finn!
There he is!
The horse is more famous than Spock!
I didn't say that.
Oh my
god, this is my iconic outfit with the tiger pelt!
Or Jack...
I'm celebrating, because I'm about...
Oh wait, no.
This is when he crushes me.
When the Buddha hand crushes me.
Wait, it's him!
Or it's the little... little kid.
Oh, this is me fighting the Celestial Court.
Because I was like, monkey deserves rights.
The Celestial Court was like, no.
Which is fucked.
Yeah, Neza.
The wheel kid.
The fire wheel kid.
It's me telling my... my brother and my bros.
My sworn brothers.
Being like, guys, don't worry, we're totally gonna win, guys.
No one's gonna die.
I'm like, bro, guys.
No one's gonna die, guys, I swear.
Yeah, this is when he removes the name off the book, yeah.
See?
I told you!
I fucking told you!
He removes it from his ear!
That's not behind his ear!
I fucking told you!
I fucking do it.
No, that's his... I told you, he puts it in his ear!
This is the front of his...
You were right, we were wrong.
We didn't vindication!
That's totally in his ear.
Oh, this is a nice song.
Oh my god, we finally did it.
We finally...
No more will people be like, Doki, you're still playing Wukong.
No, cause I finally beat it today!
No more will people ask me about this.
Black, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congrats on beating the game.
By the way, Wukong was supposed to freeze and steal your gourd after healing.
But you somehow impulse dodged his immobilize after sipping your...
Wait, did I?
I never saw... it never happened!
That's crazy.
That's actually insane.
Kyle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congratulations, Doki.
There was one more moment where he freezes you.
Oh yeah!
Yeah, DC comes out.
Hope you return to becoming monkey.
Maybe Sandy will actually be in the DC DLC.
I can't believe they didn't include Sandy.
Till the very end of the book.
Like in the ending scene.
Let me give you the super chat.
Sandy...
Even the horse was there.
Oh my god.
The who?
Guys, for those who don't know.
The bros is like...
There's like four of them.
It's him.
Five including the horse.
Chupacay.
Sifu.
And Sandy.
And the horse.
But no one really talked about it.
No one talked about him in the game.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Bite size.
Congrats on being in game.
I know that you don't really like doing long playthroughs.
But it's so much fun to watch you play this game.
Thank you for the great stream, Doki.
I will miss monkey.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
That's so cute.
Because...
Because we finished monkey...
It's time to go back to boy.
Dad of boy.
Next week though.
That's for next week though.
So finally next week we'll go back to God of War.
And people won't be like, where's God of War?
It's so many people.
It's either you still play Wukong or where's God of War.
God of Boy.
But this time.
Finally.
Next week we're finally going to play God of War.
We're going back to God of War.
I actually don't remember the controls.
So we're going to figure that out later.
This is a really good song.
I really enjoyed the game.
The game has been...
It's been so fun.
It's actually been...
This is actually one of my favorite games of the year.
Honestly.
And...
I hope it...
I don't know if the music is overpowering me.
I don't know if you guys can actually hear me.
Because the music is really loud.
Fun fact.
This song is...
Alright.
This...
Clearly we're not getting ad revenue off of this.
Well, we're not getting ad revenue.
So...
So I hope you guys...
I'll turn this song down a little bit.
But I hope you guys enjoyed watching this playthrough.
I had...
Honestly...
I had a lot of fun playing it in general.
And I'm glad to finally beat it.
And...
Show my...
I don't know.
Quote-on-quote gamer skills.
Doug, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Congrats on beating Wukong.
40 hours.
And it was so much fun to watch the entire journey.
This was my first experience with the story.
And I'm so glad I got to experience it with all you dragons.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Well, if you really enjoyed the Wukong story, I highly recommend checking out the TV and movie adaptations of Wukong.
There's a lot of classic ones.
And...
I really recommend...
A lot of the adaptations are really, really good in general.
I think my favorite ones are the TVB version and the CCTV version.
Wait, it's not...
I'm sorry.
I forgot the...
Is it?
Yeah, yeah.
It's the CCTV version too.
Yeah.
I was going to say, is it that version?
And the Zhao Xingti movies.
The...
The Zhao Xingti movies.
Steven Chao movies are my favorite adaptations.
So...
And I know a lot of them are actually on...
On...
For free on YouTube.
So it's very interesting.
It's a very fun story.
Yeah.
The Steven Chao movies are really good as well.
But yeah.
I'm so happy to play...
I'm really happy that...
That...
The...
I'm just really, really happy that the...
That it was such a nice adaptation of...
Of the...
The story in general.
It's act...
It's such a...
It's such a good...
It's just such a good show.
A really good show.
A really good...
Good series.
Like the original...
The original show.
Like...
Not show.
Sorry.
The original book.
The...
I was like...
Yes.
The show.
Sorry.
The original book as well.
The original book is like...
A lot of...
Very deep.
In general.
But yeah.
I highly recommend checking out the lore of everything.
And the adaptations.
And the original story.
And...
Yeah.
It's 2,000-ish pages.
By the way.
I read Journey...
I read Journey to the West.
And Romance of the Three Kingdoms.
And like...
Obviously, I don't remember everything.
In the story...
Guys, it was very long.
Like...
Because I read Journey to the West.
And...
I read Journey to the West.
And Romance of the Three Kingdoms.
Back to back.
So like...
Obviously, I don't remember everything.
Like...
I don't...
I don't remember everything in the stories.
But it's still really good.
Yeah.
No.
Okay.
I'll show you how long...
Romance of the Three Kingdoms is.
It's like...
I remember when I bought that book.
And I was like...
The thickness of that book.
Like...
Okay.
I'll show you.
Here's the...
Oh, my God.
I know like which one I had.
But like...
I need to show you guys how...
How thick the book is.
And the text was so tiny, too.
I read it in middle school.
Because I just love...
I love like...
Um...
Like...
I just love the books.
Or like...
I love the story behind it.
Even though like...
Romance of the Three Kingdoms is technically...
Well, it's like...
Romanticized history.
That's why it's like...
Romance of the...
But like...
This is how thick Romance of the Three Kingdoms is.
Like...
It's like...
And I was like...
This was...
This is...
Book one, by the way.
By the way...
This is...
Book one.
Um...
This is...
Book...
Because book two is also that thick.
Um...
So, you can see the one here.
You can see the one.
Book one.
Yeah.
Um...
And I read...
I read it in middle school.
Um...
But it's very...
It's...
It's really...
It's a really good read.
Um...
If you really enjoyed like...
History and like...
Um...
Samgozi.
Or just like...
Just...
It's just a really good read.
That's all I can say.
Like...
And it's...
Um...
That's a break.
Thank you for the super chat, Giga.
Thank you.
Uh...
But yeah.
Um...
Highly recommend checking it out.
Uh...
Anyway, guys.
But yeah.
Check out Journey to the West, too.
It's also really good, too.
Um...
Uh...
Anyway, guys.
As always, every...
I'm gonna call it here.
We have a very long week.
So, I wanna make sure...
Uh...
I'm gonna make sure that...
Like...
I rest my voice.
Because we did a lot of screaming and yelling.
And so...
Um...
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
And I'm happy to finally beat Wukong.
And my PC can finally rest.
Um...
Can finally rest after...
After...
Mid-dying.
In the middle of the play-through.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll read, like, two more Super Chats, by the way.
Uh...
Medi, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I bought the Three Kingdoms book.
Three volumes because of you.
And I'll do the same with Journey to the West.
You won't regret it.
It's a very interesting...
It's a very interesting read.
And, um...
If you like the story from the game, you'll enjoy the story from the book.
And I highly...
Like I said, I highly recommend checking the TV show and the movie adaptations, too.
Um...
The movies are really...
If you watch the Steven Chao movies, they're really funny.
And you'll understand, like, the lore behind it, too.
If you understand the background behind Wukong, like, you'll really...
You'll enjoy it a lot more.
Um...
But, yeah.
Uh...
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Joah, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Is that 2,000 page even longer in English?
Is...
Uh...
Well, that's...
I believe...
I...
Isn't that the...
I don't remember how long, actually.
Journey to the West.
How many pages in English?
It depends on the publisher.
It is...
Ooh.
Wow.
It depends on the book, honestly.
Just buy the book and see how...
It depends on, like, the publisher and how tiny the text is.
Um...
I read it in English.
I can't read Chinese.
Anyway, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
So, it depends on how tiny the texts are.
And, like...
Um...
How big...
How...
Who the publishers are.
Uh...
Our last...
Last Super Chat for today.
Uh...
Noriko.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Toki.
Oh, wait.
So, sorry.
Sorry.
That is from, uh...
Maoyoko.
But I meant...
Who needs revenue when you have Super Chats?
Yes.
Five dollars.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah.
We don't need our revenue, guys.
We have...
We have Super Chats.
But I do appreciate it, guys.
I really do.
Um...
But, yeah.
It was great.
It was great, everybody.
Uh...
I'll see you guys next time, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Thank you all for the Super Chats, everybody.
I really appreciate it.
Bye-bye.
Bye.